Whoa!
Batman!
I'm sorry that... I just... one of my friends linked me the fucking... linked me the tweet.
And I was like, wait, that's actually so good.
I was just like, oh my god, I love that comic.
I love that meme.
I was like, Doki, this is where my parents die.
Whoa!
Batman!
I'm sorry, it was just so good.
It actually was so fun.
That guy, whoever voice acted for Batman, bro, shout out to that guy.
That was actually a really good voice acting for Batman.
That was actually really fucking good.
Jeremy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And Mon, thank you for the 20 gifted chips.
Link, don't worry, it's pinned on my chat.
It's pinned on the chat.
Link to the video.
I love that fucking meme.
Anyway, it's Batman time.
For those who are actually new here and never watched a Doki stream before, most likely, 90%, I forgot the majority of the controls.
If I'm not playing a game right away, like if I... every time I leave a game for a while and I come back to it, I'm just like, what are the controls?
What do I do?
I think the only thing I can remember is the punching mechanic.
I think I only... where am I?
Where am I?
Okay, this is the...
Alright, punch.
Give me a sec.
Run.
Alright, Batarang.
Uh, dude, it's been three days.
Okay, detective mode.
God, I still like... I really hate the... um...
I do not... what is this?
Crouch.
Okay.
Alright, what is this?
What is RB?
What the fuck is RB?
Okay, RB is throw.
Okay.
Alright, we got this.
We got this.
We're figuring it out.
Very slowly but surely.
Wait.
Oh my gosh, there's so many plays.
Oh, hey!
Ridley!
Nice.
Always want more Ridley trophies.
Alright, RB is grapple.
Okay, I got this.
I hate the detective mode because the detect... the...
Sorry, detective mode makes it so that it's harder to like... see what...
Like, the flashes.
I hate the flashes so much.
Uh...
Broomstick, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Glad to see you.
So happy to hear you're still good stream.
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Pretty sure this is not the right way.
Yeah, it's like the little flashbang.
I really don't like it.
Oh.
Alright, time to beat up.
Do I need to be stealthy?
No.
Hey.
Wait, how do I dodge?
Oh, it's okay.
They're just dead.
Alright.
Wait, wait!
No, I forgot how to do the finisher move!
Okay.
Um... Why?
Okay, there we go.
We're fine.
Alright, it's coming back to me.
It's like driving a car.
I haven't drove a car in ten years.
But it's just... it's just like driving a car.
There you go.
It's almost just like driving a car.
Alright.
I don't think I should touch a car for... I don't think...
Condition unconscious.
Oh, I can like see their heart rate.
Alright, nice.
At least they're just unconscious.
Uh... I mean like if I can't kill...
Okay, not gonna lie.
If I can't kill, I feel like legally...
Like in the bat rules, I should be able to use a crowbar.
As long as I don't kill anybody.
Like if I can use the battering rams, I should be able to use them.
Because like... I feel like batter... the batterings are like... they're still metal.
Right?
So legally, if you think about it, I should be able to also use a crowbar.
Because I'm already giving them brain damage.
Right?
So if I'm giving...
Okay, yes.
For people like...
Batman doesn't kill.
I'm not gonna kill them.
Like... making them paralyzed is not killing.
It's just very cruel.
But they're not gonna die.
Like... they're not going to die.
I'm just shutting... I don't know how to dodge in the middle of kicking ass.
Super thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like, why do you assume I'm gonna aim for the head?
I can... I can...
I can aim for...
Jesus Christ!
Think of the Jason Fats!
He lived!
He's still alive!
You can't say that!
Poetry guys.
He's still alive!
Like, a serious injury.
But like... Batman doesn't care.
He doesn't care if someone's seriously injured.
Let me introduce you to old Josh.
He's a good boy.
I'm talking about you and your people.
Hello.
Hello, turkey.
Are you allowed to eat pizza?
Is that...
Of course I'm allowed to eat pizza.
I fucking eat tomatoes all the time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like, all I'm saying is that...
Look, Batman picks and chooses a lot with his rules.
That's all I'm saying.
Alright, hello.
Oh shit!
Don't worry, I got you.
I got you!
Oh my god!
It's okay.
But all he uses are bat things.
He can't pick up a weapon without bat in front of the name.
I can literally call this a bat bar!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I mean, you're still getting air in there.
As long as the gas doesn't...
You really think you can beat the Joker?
I can't even beat the Joker.
Can you control the ventilation system in there?
Drag.
It's a no go.
He disabled remote access.
I'll find a way.
Wait, does he have like a fucking hook for a hand?
Where's your hand, sir?
Wait, that's not even like...
I guess like Arkham Asylum doesn't pay very well.
Because that's not even a prosthetic.
That's literally a hook hand.
Holy shit.
Where is my...
Where is my funding going?
I'm fucking...
Where's Wayne?
Where is my funding going?
I funded like five million dollars to this fucking asylum.
And all you can get is a fucking metal...
That's not even good.
I feel like if you have a metal literally attached...
Like, how does that help you?
It's not even a prosthetic.
You can't even pick anything.
You might as well just have a stump hand.
Like...
Yes.
This is a prison.
You...
Like, I feel like there's no actual use of it.
I'm not even used to that.
Because you can't pick anything.
What are you gonna do?
Make holes or something?
On like pieces of paper?
Like...
Go put the TV down.
Oh, use it to press buttons on the TV?
Oh yeah, sorry.
All the money went to the TV.
High on caffeine.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, you eat tomatoes?
Wouldn't that be capitalism?
Someone clearly didn't know my lore.
I don't know.
I have an entire stream dedicated to eating all my tomato children.
Open the door.
Oh, the door is blocked.
Okay, what do we do?
All right, clearly we don't do anything here.
All right, yeah, the weak should eat the strong.
Exactly.
Now you're speaking my language.
It's called survival of the fittest.
Bruce Wayne has money.
You're Batman.
Right, thank you for the soup.
Super chat, thank you, thank you.
All right, check the map.
No!
I'm going to figure this out by pure instinct.
This is called the gamer instinct.
Can I just leave that guy to die?
Does he actually matter?
I'm pretty sure he doesn't matter.
Okay, let's see.
Where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go?
I clearly can't do anything here.
Can I jump?
I'm gonna jump.
Okay, I should not have jumped.
Use detective mode?
No!
Okay, I should use detective mode.
Oh.
Use to remove purify.
Okay, but how do I get there?
Can I just...
Can I just do this?
Okay, no.
What do I do?
Condition 10.
I'm terrified.
Can I just kill him?
There you go.
I mean, he's unconscious, so he's still okay.
I can't let this man die.
Well, that's unfortunate then.
He's okay.
I mean, look.
See, he still has a heart rate.
Like...
What's gonna happen to him?
I mean, he's still okay.
That was a big fall.
Look, he's okay!
Look at him.
Look.
We can...
Look, see?
It's not even red.
It's like yellow.
Alright.
We gotta figure this out.
Okay.
Where the fuck do I...
Let's see.
Like, see?
He's unconscious.
Guys, he's not dead.
He's just unconscious.
I can't fucking grapple anywhere.
Where is it?
Where do I go?
I feel like this is not where I should be going.
He's just...
I'm sorry.
I'm just gonna leave him.
I feel like we don't have to do anything with this guy.
Glide?
Glide where?
I feel like I can't even...
Okay, let's try.
We...
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm okay.
Let's try this again.
I can...
I got this.
Wait, wait, wait.
I have so much HP.
I have so much...
How do I glide again?
There we go.
God damn it!
I'm so...
Okay.
I got this.
We...
I'll eventually make it!
It's okay.
I'm alive.
Oh...
Hey...
Someone help Batbaby.
I was...
Sorry.
I didn't realize there was a limit to how many times I could do...
No!
I have to do this again?
God damn it.
Okay.
I didn't realize.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
I wanted to beat him up again anyway.
Alright.
It's alright.
It's fine.
Alright.
But he's laughing!
He's clearly having a good time.
Alright.
We'll be fine.
Let's see.
Alright.
If he's laughing, why are you dead?
I tinked out!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Yo, Golden Trophy Bird.
Hope you're doing well.
Thank you!
Yeah, I'm doing great.
I'm fine.
I'm good to play Batman.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
We can do this again.
Alright.
Don't worry.
You'll be okay.
Yay!
See?
He's fine.
I got XP!
If it's not fine, why did I get XP?
Just think of that.
If...
If it was not fine, why did it give me XP?
Oh my god.
It's right here.
Guys.
Who the fuck said glide?
Who said glide?
It was literally right there.
Oh.
Whoops.
Sorry.
No!
I thought I fended.
Now glide.
Oh.
Wait.
Is that not...
Did I not fix the gas?
Where else would there be gas?
I thought I fixed it.
Used to remove...
Wait.
Where did I not fix it?
Look.
It's going on.
It lessened?
Oh!
Okay.
Glide to...
Part above the gas.
Okay.
Weeeeee.
Nice.
I did it.
Alright.
Where do I have to go?
See?
It's okay.
Look.
He's still unconscious.
Alright.
Nice.
I'm doing it.
Okay.
There's...
Yeah.
There it is.
Oh.
Boop.
There we go.
I'm doing it!
Of course I am.
I'm Batman.
Alright.
Is that everything?
Sam!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Hey Doki.
I'm the one who invented the wallow swallow thing.
If you have time, I was wondering if you could give a short motivational speech for anybody who is down in the dumps.
Love you platonically.
Always...
Always swallow with the help of me.
Alex, thank you for the gifted ship.
Thank you.
Is that everything?
What else is there?
Oh hey.
Boop.
Wait.
Did I get the xp?
I did.
Nice.
What do I glide?
What else?
Is this still laughing gas?
No, it's not.
Okay.
Boop.
All defense agreed.
We've got full power.
What do you mean?
I literally solved this myself.
You guys said glide.
You guys gave me instructions.
It's not the same.
It comes out of order and I figured it out myself.
Nice.
Look at that.
Not the Joker?
I mean, I guess like, cause like the killer croc ate his hand.
I still think that is like the worst prosthetic you can ever get.
Because you can't do anything with that.
Like, it's literally just two hooks.
What can you grab?
I guess like your shirt?
What if you need to like...
Like, it's so useless.
Like, what do you grab?
What?
Oh shit, he's a real person.
In 2003.
Hello.
I saved your life.
You're welcome, guys.
So what's going on?
My radio went dead soon after you brought Joker in.
We lock him up, he gets out and more people die.
If I just have one minute alone with that animal.
A back scratcher.
Who's gonna use this?
Patient's name is Edward Nygma.
What if they use the bathroom?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can talk about your childhood
fascination with the...
To be fair, a lot of villains have like terrible childhoods.
Explain your compulsive behavior.
That's why they hate the world.
Very well.
I was determined to prove him wrong.
So I entered a contest.
A prize to the kid who could figure out an almost impossible...
He was convinced I had cheated.
He kept yelling, you must have cheated.
Admit it, you moron, you cheated.
I swore I did.
Whoa.
And he hit me for lying.
Where's the mom?
I'm sorry to hear that, Edward.
He was right.
Wait, he did cheat?
You're a fucking...
You're a fucking cheater?
Oh my God.
I can't believe it, Riddler.
What about integrity?
Astrid, thank you for the gifted ship.
Thank you.
All right, where do I go?
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
I already got a doc.
Oh, we have to get multiple doctors.
I forgot.
It's not just one doctor.
Okay, but is there like anything important here?
At all?
I feel like there was like a vent above here, right?
Wait.
Oh, I can open doors.
Hello.
Oh, hey, he's a guy.
See, he's alive.
See?
Look at that.
Batman never kills.
I told you I can't kill.
There's a riddle in there.
There is?
Wait, where is it?
Is it in here?
Because I can't open that yet.
I think it has to be in there.
It's fine.
We don't need it yet.
I told you.
Just like, you know, permanent damage to the physical body.
But that's okay.
That's what doc.
That's why we're saving the doctors.
That's why.
Oh, it's in the mirror.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Newspaper articles in room with man.
Oh shit.
What was the, what was this firefly too hot?
All right.
Let's see.
Don't worry.
I'm not going to do that.
Okay.
This is important, sir.
Wait.
There you go.
So they're too small.
What else am I supposed to look at?
How is it too small?
Is it because I'm looking at it too hard?
Oh, zoom in.
Okay.
All right.
Clearly not.
How much more?
How do I zoom?
I have to zoom in.
Oh, okay.
There we go.
Alright, here we go.
I did it!
Firefly escapes Gotham on high alert.
Oh my god, I recently...
YouTube shorts, thank you.
For destroying the comics industry.
I learned about... there's like this villain in Batman called the Calendar Man.
And like, before they retconned him to be like a super serious villain...
He would like kill villains on holidays.
Which, I don't know.
It feels like...
Okay, I... in my opinion...
If the villain, all he does is kill people...
Wait...
Kill people on holidays...
Then like, you know who did it.
Like...
Oh shit, what?
Cause it's like...
Oh my god, somebody died on Christmas.
He was murdered.
Who could it be?
Well, the only person that kills people during the holidays...
Is this one particular villain.
So it has to be Calendar Man.
Like...
It just feels very...
I don't know.
Like, if you're gonna kill somebody...
I feel like you should...
It should be more random than a fucking holiday.
Nice, thank you for the free stuff.
I actually thought it was gonna be like...
Nice.
Yay!
That's the point.
Some villains like that...
But it's stupid!
Like...
They don't wanna get caught!
So why would you do the one thing that gets you caught?
Okay, we gotta go for this one.
Why is it yellow?
Okay.
He did more than kill people.
He did a ton of holiday themed crimes.
Then you know who did it!
Monster, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It doesn't matter!
It's still on a holiday!
They wanna get caught?
The rehabilitation doesn't work, Batman!
He's encouraging... Oh, is this Saw?
Just not for me.
It's true!
You really are the world's greatest detective!
It's not even a puzzle.
The hell?
Get down there, boys!
It's a trap!
Oh yeah, really?
Who would've thought this was a trap all along?
Oh my god!
He's alone in there by himself!
What could happen?
Wow, okay.
Hey man.
I'm trying to do a combo move right now.
Excuse me, why are you disturbing my combo?
Oh shit, no!
Come on!
Let me beat him up!
Let me give your friend brain damage!
Nice.
Come on.
Let me punch you in the dick!
Come on, you know you want to!
Okay, nice.
Easy.
Excuses.
Yay!
You're too full of yourself, Bats.
I'm just softening you up.
Think of this as a preview to the main event.
You'll see.
What's up here?
I'll free you later.
Sorry, this is important.
Counter button?
What do you mean?
I counted so much!
Okay, Arkham Knight Shift.
Dr. T.
Elliot.
Dr. P. Young.
Dr. ... Wait!
Time.
Week 1, Week 2.
Wait, there's only one doctor per week?
Week 2 for night shift?
Killer Croc Transfer?
Week 2?
Nurses?
That is not a lot of nurses.
For like, an asylum...
Because the asylum is filled with like, crazy people...
Because that's what an asylum is for.
I feel like 9 nurses...
That is...
That is definitely understaffed.
That is definitely understaffed...
I'll have solved all the puzzles by now.
Yeah, this feels incredibly understaffed.
Hush.
Oh, that's the crazy guard!
Right?
Oh no, it wasn't the guard.
Okay, this is a different person.
I know there was a Batman movie about this.
I just realized how many like...
There was like... Did you know they made a movie about Soviet...
Soviet Superman and Batman?
And I was like, what the fuck?
There are so many different types of DC movies.
Yeah, called the Red... It's like, what if Superman didn't land in America and landed in fucking Russia?
And I was like, holy fuck.
Yeah.
And then like, Russian Batman kills everybody.
Like, I was just like, holy shit!
Russian Batman does not give a fuck!
He murders everyone!
Um...
Uh...
Anyway...
Coolera, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's the freaking bat.
Yeah.
Yeah, Russian... Russian Batman kills everyone.
And then Lex Luthor becomes fucking president of the United States of America.
Okay.
A childhood sociopath.
When his plans failed, partly due to the surgical skills of Thomas Wayne, Bruce's father, Elliot Blaine Bruce.
An incredibly skilled surgeon as an adult, Elliot planned an elaborate revenge scheme on Batman.
He disguised himself as the villain Hush, his face covered in bandages, but was in the end defeated and unmasked by the Dark Knight.
Hush still plots revenge against Batman, generating complicated schemes with surgical precision.
Wait, so he's just Batman with too much money?
So he's literally just Bruce Wayne with a lot of fucking money.
That's cool.
But instead he's evil.
But if he's like, okay, all I'm saying is that, like, okay, Batman, he runs a company that develops weapons.
Tommy Elliot is just a surgeon.
Hahahaha!
Where is he?
How is he?
I don't know how you can compare to, like, anything else.
He's literally just a surgeon.
Like, how is he getting his weapon?
He has guns.
Yes, but clearly they're not great weapons.
He's literally just a surgeon.
Batman at least has a fucking, like, what is it, Fortune 500 company that specifically develops weapons and armor.
Um...
Great physical strength.
Augmented by a hatred of Bruce Wayne.
World-class surgeon.
Capable of extraordinary medical breakthroughs.
Master of disguise.
But... how?
How is he a master of disguise?
He's just... he just has...
It's still gonna be the same body!
Hahahaha!
I have so many questions about this one character.
I don't... extreme...
He's just so hateful.
He changes his face?
But he still has the same body type!
Whoa.
Don't you need to be, like, have anesthesia for...
For, like, any type of surgery?
Holy shit.
There's no way.
Okay.
Alright.
I know, like, we keep...
We keep interrupting this game.
We keep interrupting this game play with, like, fun facts.
But, like...
Eventually, by the time...
If you keep fucking giving yourself plastic surgery...
There's, like, nothing left to fix.
Hahahaha!
There is!
Because, like...
At that...
Are you okay?
Also, are you okay, Dr. Adrian Chen?
Like...
You are mentally not okay.
Um...
But, like...
The more plastic surgery you get...
The more fucked up your face is gonna get.
Um...
Anyway...
Not so Deadpool.
American Batman's parents were killed.
Soviet Batman had...
Oh my god.
They tortured me.
Set me as bait.
I'm sorry.
Are you okay?
I think I will be okay.
Thank you for stopping them.
How did they torture you?
Oh my god.
They're syringes.
Are you okay?
How much...
How many, like...
Meds did they put in you?
They tortured me.
Set me as bait.
I don't think he's gonna be okay.
I'm sorry.
Can I go through here?
I don't think I can.
How do I deactivate this?
Alright.
Good night.
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
Doki Hush's body type is just a large white man.
Do you have any idea how many of those are in the DC universe?
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Oh my god.
You got me there.
It's true.
You got...
You got me there.
Do you want to get a present?
Yay!
More XP.
Let's go.
Alright, let's see.
Where's the last one?
The last one is all the way over here.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Alright, I figured it out.
It's this way.
Presence!
There's a lot of meds.
Oh, that's a lot of shotgun bullets.
Oh, where do I go?
Okay, this way.
Oops!
Sometimes the map is really difficult to navigate.
Hello!
I swear, everybody in the DC Universe is jacked as fuck.
Everyone has a 20-year membership in...
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Really, Joker?
Is this the best people you can send?
Woop!
There you go.
Nice.
I love just pressing A.
I mean X.
Look down!
I had to look down my controller there.
It's all just...
There is a problem in there, in the Gotham water supply.
Whoa.
Oh shit, that's a lot of people.
Wait!
I'm gonna tag this wall.
No.
How do I tag the wall?
How do I, how do I do it?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah!
I did it.
Wait.
Wait, there was an innocent person over there?
No.
I didn't realize there was an innocent person there.
I didn't.
Alright, don't worry.
Okay, I didn't realize...
Okay, look.
I didn't realize that, you know, there were important people here.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
Oh hey, they're really listening.
I thought like they were just having a nice conversation.
Like, together.
How is there more than one wall?
Don't worry, it's not legal.
Okay, I'm not killing civilians.
They're the ones killing civilians.
I'm just here to have a good time.
What the fuck?
Oh, okay, there's the other wall.
Alright, I'm gonna tag this wall, I guess.
Alright.
I fucked up.
No.
No!
Let me finish tagging!
I pressed the wrong one!
I pressed...
I'm sorry, I can't read!
I pressed R, B!
I was like, hold R, T.
Oh, hold R, B.
Hold R, B.
Alright.
Okay, I figured it out.
Guys, this time...
This time it's different.
Okay.
Alright.
R, T.
There we go.
Guys, I don't use controller very often.
Guys, is it noticeable that I don't use controller?
And...
Dr. Young!
First try!
Let's go!
Dr. Young!
First try.
You definitely did not die two times before I saved you.
Unfortunately, yes.
But not for long.
I'm very confident in my job.
The warden was very specific.
He wanted Joker cured.
Bad publicity will affect his campaign for mayor.
That'll be the least of it.
God.
I almost forgot.
They said they were moving through the facility.
Hunting down the other doctors.
Oh, do not worry, Penny Young.
You were the last one I saved.
Don't worry, doctor.
All the medical staff are safe.
Yeah, all of them are safe now.
They're all...
You were...
You were the last one.
All right.
Let's see.
I want to make sure I...
Make sure I didn't miss anything here.
Let's see...
Is there anything... Is there anything I'm missing?
JP, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I didn't fuck up, guys!
I didn't fuck up!
I made a slight miscalculation.
And no lies were injured in the process.
Okay?
As the greatest detective in the world, it was just a little oopsie.
That can be... It's fixable.
Where's the last present?
Hello!
I'm so calm.
Alright, nice.
See?
I told you!
Told you I'm calm!
Nice!
Oh wait, I should put back the battery right now so I can...
Nice.
Boop!
Fucking popped out like Marilyn Monroe there.
Don't keep me messed up!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, where do I go?
Uh... Oh, I gotta go back.
I was so calm.
What do you mean?
I beat the shit out of him.
There's a children's area?
There's fucking super villains and we put a children's area in the asylum?
What the fuck is wrong with Gotham?
What?
Evil kids.
Bro!
Why is there a children's area?
There's a mansion?
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think she's beginning to figure out the problem where I come to the asylum.
There's like... This is not even like a problem.
This is like...
This is a mistake.
Alright,
don't worry.
We got... Oh shit, they have guns.
Okay, that's not good.
Okay, they have guns now.
Alright, let's see.
Oh fuck.
They have shotguns.
Wait a minute.
Oh wait, I wanna grab these.
Okay.
Maybe if I do that and I grapple here.
And then...
Alright, wait, where are they?
Where the fuck are they?
Where are they going?
Okay, they're going here.
Okay.
Let me head to the gargoyle.
And then...
Come over here.
Come on!
How the fuck am I supposed to get you over here?
No... No Batman.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Use detective mode?
Why do I need to use detective mode?
I need them to like come over to me.
Wait, the floor is breakable?
The floor is breakable?
No it's not.
Oh yeah it is.
Oh shit, you're right!
Okay.
The structural weakness critter.
Why is there structural weakness?
Did no one fucking do anything to this critter?
All I'm saying is...
Why the fuck is there structural weakness in it?
Okay.
Alright.
This whole entire area is fucked man.
Can I just land there and...
Okay, wait.
And then...
Pew!
Tagging it real fast.
You know why.
Every time I learn more about how poorly this place is built, I'm still surprised and I don't know why.
I should stop being surprised about how terrible this place is.
Hello?
Come over here.
Come on!
I have the wall!
Over here!
Come on!
Get over here!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Yeah.
Yeah, I did.
Don't look up.
No?
Yeah, come over there.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Wait, where are they?
Where are they going?
You know, I might as well just kill this guy.
You know, fuck it.
Oh shit!
No!
Oh wait, nice.
He's unconscious!
Okay, I'll take that.
I'll take that actually.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Okay, I'm just making it much more complicated than it should be.
Wait, wait, wait.
Yes!
No!
Get over here!
Okay, I fucked up.
I thought he...
I thought he was gonna get closer to me.
Yes!
Nice!
Alright.
I failed successfully.
And then glad kick.
Yay!
Easy.
But uh...
Failed successfully.
I told you guys I can do this.
Alright, where am I supposed to go now?
Can I actually upgrade my stuff?
No, I don't have enough.
But, dookie, Batman does have guns.
Two incredibly well-toned guns.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, poetry guys.
Alright.
Backseat time.
What do I upgrade?
What's important?
I don't know.
What is important, guys?
Extreme violence.
Alright.
What is important, guys?
HP?
Throw?
Health?
Okay, health.
Alright, here.
Nice.
Martha!
Alright, nice, alright.
HP time.
Okay, where do I go?
Do I still have to go here?
Return to the doctors and pick up Gordon's...
uh...
tobacco trail.
Okay.
Alright, I gotta figure this out.
Is it like...
here?
No?
Okay, wrong way.
Wrong way.
I'll forever be lost in this hellhole.
Oh my god.
Okay, this way.
Up I go.
Cool, man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh!
Do it!
No pause!
Joker would never do it because like, he gets his kicks going by having Batman as like an archenemy.
Got a few more surprises in store for you.
Prepare to face your fears.
His greatest fear is like, losing Batman and then becoming an office worker.
Nice.
Holy scarecrow.
Wait, what?
Wait, scarecrow?
What the fuck is scarecrow?
Oh, Sean.
Are you gonna take your hat off to Harley bats?
Wait, is it gonna become a horror story?
Is it gonna come out last?
What is Batman scared of?
Riddles!
I'm scared of not getting that riddle trophy.
Haha!
Joker, no matter what, there is one fangirl out there that would love to see you in a thong.
I.E.
Harley.
Tax is my number one fear.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, wait, what?
I just...
Developed by Wendy's control points are considered hack-proof.
That is such a fucking lie!
Why does it keep telling me it's hack-proof?
It is not hack-proof!
Even Joker can fucking hack into this.
Okay, let's put this on.
Hanging this.
Nice.
Okay.
What every billionaire's fear of Texas.
Yeah, I feel like Batman has multiple offshore accounts.
Gordon?
Gordon!
Watch it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah, it is canon.
His biggest fear is the IRS.
I forgot about that.
Oh.
All right, let's go.
Let me in.
Let me in!
Gordon?
Gordon, you okay?
Hey.
Gordon?
Gordon, look at me.
You got a blink or your eyes are gonna dry out.
I'm sorry, Jim.
Wait, is he dead?
What?
They just killed off Jim Gordon?
Wait, no.
I have to be having a nightmare right now.
There's no fucking way Jim Gordon just dies like that.
There is no way.
This has to be a nightmare.
Batman, wake up!
You there.
Please hang up your phone.
Hunt down Commissioner Gordon.
There's no fucking way.
There's no way.
There's no way they just kill him like that.
I must be dreaming.
I must be having a nightmare from the scarecrow.
Yeah, this is definitely a nightmare.
Okay, look.
Look, this place sucks, but it doesn't suck that much.
The morgue.
Oh, shit.
People are gonna come alive, aren't they?
I don't like this.
Oh.
I am not a fan of this.
I am not a fan.
When did this become Outlast?
Wait,
this is the morgue.
Where are the dead bodies?
Hello?
How do I get out?
How do I?
I don't know.
How do I get out?
I don't know how!
Do I just...
I'm thinking!
You can't keep saying get out of here.
You don't tell me how!
The voices.
They're getting louder.
Okay, fine.
Fine.
Fine!
Oh, shit.
Oh, hey.
Oh, he did want me to get out of here.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Are you telling me I should have got out of there?
No way.
Dad?
This is where my parents died.
No way.
Mom?
Turns out it was dad.
You see?
I should have got out of there.
Jesus Christ.
Trauma.
Is this going to be long?
Is this going to be me?
Bruce?
Oh, scarecrow.
The voices told me to...
Whoa!
Well, I actually got goosebumps from that.
That's so fucking cool.
Oh, I don't have detective mode.
No.
No!
He took away the one thing I have!
I'm the world's greatest detective, but I can't get into detective mode!
Stephen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The voices told you to get...
I like how they were like, get out of there.
I was like...
What do I do, chat?
I don't understand!
Oh, shit.
Giant scarecrow.
Oh, my little bat.
You're in my world now!
Put a shirt on.
Oh, shit.
I'm dead.
Ow.
Wait, what do I do?
I just run?
I'm just gonna run.
Okay.
Where...
Haha!
Okay.
Okay, I gotta go up.
I'm just gonna wait.
Alright.
Does this scan me?
Nice.
Okay, that does it.
Alright.
Where do I go?
Do I... what?
Huh?
What happened?
Wait.
Is this the... this has to be the...
Just punch the wall, scarecrow!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Please!
Tag faster!
Please tag faster!
Oh shit!
Okay!
He got so fast!
Dude, this trip is crazy!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Okay, how the fuck was I supposed to know he was gonna go faster?
Alright.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Just gotta run.
And then crouch.
Alright.
If he really wanted to kill me, he could just punch the wall.
It's not that hard.
Crouch, crouch, crouch, crouch, crouch!
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Okay, we gotta bring out...
I wish he could tag things faster, but he still needs to draw the bat signal on everything.
Alright.
Please, please, please, Batman!
Please!
It's not that quick!
Nice.
I'm not here.
Where could I be?
Whoa!
I wonder where I could be right about now!
Okay.
Nice.
There's no way he's gonna look past this wall, right?
There's no fucking way.
Okay, I don't know his pattern right now, so I'm like, scared.
I'm actually scared.
Okay.
Nice.
I swear, if he like fucking looks back as like a little gotcha moment...
What was that?
My biggest fear!
Light!
That's fucking right!
Get flash banged!
What silent killer of the oceans can be found in a tiny jar?
What?
Cat?
Wait.
What?
Alright.
Character bio.
Where is he?
Is that him?
The scarecrow?
Taunted and bullied as a youth, Jonathan Crane vowed to overcome his fear through the study of psychology and biochemistry.
Kicked out of his university for experimenting on human subjects, Crane then adopted the identity of the scarecrow and armed himself with specialized fear-inducing gas that makes the person's deepest phobias become frightening and frighteningly real.
His ongoing criminal reign of terror makes him one of Batman's most psychologically dangerous foes.
Stupid Crane.
You have to go through animals and then experiment on humans.
Because apparently that's how ethical... apparently that's more ethical.
You can experiment on humans all you want!
You just gotta follow the process!
Alright, let's see.
Professional... what the fuck?
Occupation.
Professional criminal.
That's his job.
Alright.
He just needs to follow the process and then he can experiment on as many humans as he wants.
Welcome to science.
The jar.
Oh, there's the jar.
There it is.
What is that?
Is that a finger?
Oh shit, no.
Not my explosive jar.
Subject too small?
Do I have to fucking scan this?
Okay.
Alright.
What the fuck is that?
What is that?
Oops, sorry.
The great white shark.
A crooked financer who stole millions of dollars.
Warren Wright thought he'd scored a legal victory when his insanity pili went through.
But when he got to... I actually don't know this criminal.
But when he got to Arkham Asylum, he realized his mistake.
Driven insane by the other inmates, he was also disfigured by an encounter with Mr. Freeze that left him without hair... Oh my god, it's Voldemort!
A nose, ears, or lips.
Calling himself the great white shark.
He filed his teeth into fangs to more perfectly resemble his new namesake.
Putting the financial skills to use, he has become a major player in Gotham's underground crime scene.
Running a number of rackets from his... Oh, so he's like the... the accountant for like, criminals.
He's like the main accountant!
Warren White!
The underrated villain.
I mean...
I mean, he's an accountant!
So...
Like, wow!
I'm so scared.
What she uses for her variety of criminal purposes.
Scarred visage that makes him resemble a shark.
Thief sharpened...
Like, I'm just saying...
He's... He's just... He's an accountant.
He's not like, an actual villain.
He's just there to help the villains do their taxes.
Cause like, I assume the villains can't have like regular accountants, right?
So like, obviously it makes sense that, like, they have to get a villain accountant.
Also, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
I'm back, guys!
Okay, the best part about like, playing on controller is that I can actually...
I can actually just...
I'm like lounging on my chair.
While playing this game.
Thanks for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Are your eyes green or gray?
Um, it's green.
If it's sometimes gray, it's because I accidentally have the green screen on.
That's the only reason why sometimes it's gray.
Okay, oh hey.
What's the... Why is there arrow signs?
Am I that stupid?
I need...
Is Batman and Batman actually challenged that the game was like...
I knew it!
Knew it!
There's no way they would just kill Gordon!
That fast!
Same here.
Just roll with the dots.
It gets easier once you get in.
It really does.
But really...
Whoa!
Shit!
Don't worry.
Oh, I can't... Wait, can I dodge that?
No, I can't.
If I just keep...
If I just keep punching!
He'll die eventually!
Okay.
Oh shit.
No.
No, come on!
Let me fucking finish him!
Alright, nice.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I did not need to dick punch that guy.
Alright, nice.
How come I can't dodge?
Nice!
Oh wait, it won't let me like...
It won't let me punch him when like he's upright.
No more tricks!
Just one more!
I don't know this puzzle.
You're not the riddler.
Alright.
Okay, he wants me to go this way, but what if I don't go that way?
What if I go this way?
Okay, actually I don't know where this way goes.
Okay, does this go back?
Like...
Okay, maybe I should go this way.
I didn't really...
Okay, but like isn't Gordon... I feel like Gordon's pretty fucking shit at his job.
Not gonna lie.
His whole thing was like to defeat corruption.
But like...
Does it look like it's going well?
Crime doesn't come cheap if they got to pay their taxes.
Rob, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He's trying his best.
Is this bear the bane of his life?
I'm gonna get to Harley without anyone realizing.
I'll give you your next present.
Fail, and the old carter dies.
Hell, I may even give you Harley.
Bro, what the fuck?
You could use a new sidekick.
Bro, why do you keep fucking giving Harley a...
Harley a way?
No, it's a stealth mission!
Okay.
Alright, it's time to stealth.
Alright, not gonna lie.
The fact that he keeps giving away Harley...
It's not great.
I only saw 10%.
Alright, let's open this.
Yeah, this is really giving me some heavy NTR vibes, man.
Joking, I'm not... I don't really want to know what's going on in your bedroom life right about now.
But like, as Batman, um...
I don't know.
I... Batman has enough lady problems at the moment.
So like, I really don't care.
Thank you, Super Chat!
Thank you!
Joker more like the cucker!
Oh my god!
Ah, yes.
Goo number 20 hundred is gonna kill me.
Alright, here I go.
Harley, please.
Is this really what you want, Harley?
Can I kill him?
Or do I just walk past?
Do I just...
walk past him?
There's no way he'd notice.
There's no way.
There's no...
You know what?
Fuck it.
There's no way, right?
There's no way.
Nice.
Alright.
It's okay.
If I don't see what they actually look like, Um...
I can't humanize him.
That's fucked up!
That's what like...
That's like an actual, like, strategy.
Oh, hey, Ridley!
Nice.
As long as you don't humanize them, and you don't see what they look like, it's okay.
Get over here.
So, like, I'm not actually killing anybody.
Alright.
Can he see me through the...
Can he see me through this?
It's great.
There's just skeletons.
Skeletons aren't real.
Alright.
Is that him?
Skeletons aren't real.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Woah, woah, woah.
Come on.
Turn around.
Okay.
Nice.
So...
I like how I, like, jab him in the fucking back.
Alright.
We gotta get the last guy.
Okay.
How the fuck do I get the last one?
Guess what's inside you right now.
Blood!
What else would be inside me?
Okay.
You can't see me from there.
Wait.
Who's that over there?
A blue skeleton.
Hahaha.
I'm just gonna...
Okay.
It would really suck if he just turns around.
There you go!
What's...
Yeah!
Tomato!
See?
Okay.
There's a no right?
Holy fuck!
Okay.
That would've been...
That would've been awkward.
Okay.
How do I do this?
Alright.
A little oopsie there, but it's okay.
They can't hear.
How do I get past this?
Okay.
Oh!
You can't hear this?
Okay.
Pick up.
Can I just drop down?
Hahaha!
What if I just drop down?
Okay.
I'm like worried if I drop down.
Do I drop?
Wait.
Is that...
That's glass, right?
Is that glass?
I can't tell if that's glass.
Oh shit!
It is!
Okay.
Can I... No I can't.
Now I can be broken with enough force.
Okay.
Rrrrrrrr.
Tagging it?
Okay.
I feel like I might die if I do this.
I'll stand over.
Nice!
Gordon!
Please just kill him, Gordon!
Batman will keep thinking rehabilitation will work!
Gordon!
Just kill him!
Oh!
Am I killing to you?
Am I?
Good!
You're going to love this next bit.
It wants Dr. Young's login.
Never mind that.
Get behind me.
Now.
Bane.
Oh shit.
Wait.
That's Bane?
I thought he broke up.
What is Joker doing?
Dr. Young.
The brooch.
What say we cut him down?
Huh?
No!
Wait.
Was one of the doctors...
Was that doctor I saved evil?
Gordon!
Run!
Oh fuck!
No!
Please don't break my back!
Oh wait.
Like I said.
That's not going to do anything.
No!
My back!
Oh shit.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Oh shit.
How do I do this?
Oh!
I forgot to dodge!
How do I dodge?
How do you dodge?
Oh shit.
Oh!
Okay.
Guys.
How the fuck do you dodge again?
I don't remember!
Okay.
Can I just punch you?
Oh!
Fuck!
Bro!
Oh my god!
Bane please!
Please!
Oh my... Okay.
I figured it out.
Oh god.
Okay.
What if I just throw batarangs at you?
What did I do?
I wasn't the doctor!
What the fuck did I do?
Okay.
Alright.
Come over here.
There's a wall!
Oh shit!
There was a wall.
Okay.
What the fuck did I do?
What did I do?
I...
Oh shit!
Okay.
That was my bad.
How could you not run into a wall to stun Bane while he is charging?
Oh.
Okay.
I have to stun him while he's charging.
I thought to make him run into a wall.
Okay.
Oh!
Alright.
There you go.
Come on.
Charge me.
That's right.
That's fucking right!
Oh.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean that.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Yeah!
That's fucking right!
Get a concussion.
It's the legal way where you can't die.
Can't see.
That's right.
Open your eyes.
I don't want to get near.
I don't want...
I got near him.
He fucking punched me back.
Wait!
He can heal himself?
Whoa!
Okay.
Oh shit!
Oh!
I do have to get near him!
Nice!
Yoink!
Alright.
I figured it out.
Guys!
I'm learning!
...
Wait, what?
That's not fair.
This is a 1v1!
Wait a minute, this is a 1v1!
Wait a minute.
What happened to the 1v1?
Oh, I am so fucked.
Please.
PLEASE!
NO!
I CAN'T GET AWAY FROM THAT!
Please, where's myself here?
Please, friendly fire!
Friendly fire!
YES, THERE IS!
Okay, there's friendly fire.
That's all that matters.
I'm so happy there's friendly fire.
Holy fuck.
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine.
Alright, I'm learning.
That's fucking right.
They're dead.
I'm like one hit.
I'm so fucked.
Bro, I'm so fucked.
Oh my god, please.
Please hit each other.
Please.
Oh, please!
Yes!
I'm just... I'm just hoping...
Nice!
Okay, I don't have to worry about them.
I just need them to hit each other.
That's fucking right.
What are you gonna do, huh?
If I keep running!
There you go.
Nice.
YES!
1 HP!
And a dream!
It's like bowling.
It really is, actually.
It actually is like bowling.
I learned I didn't have to do anything.
Thank fucking god there's friendly fire.
Ooh!
The Batmobile!
I'm fine, Jim.
Where's Quinn?
Gone.
Must have gotten loose while Bane was throwing you around.
We need to get you off the island.
I'm not a rookie.
I can handle myself.
Oh!
What the fuck?
How do you still have all those juices?
No!
Not my back!
Land the Bruja!
No, Bane.
This time I break you!
Oh shit!
Oh ho ho ho ho!
My car!
Bro, that was like... 50 million dollars!
Bruce!
Jim, get back here!
We could have... we could have solved the homeless problem in Gotham City with that money.
Not the Batmobile.
Tax rate up.
It has to be the doctor that went back to the mansion to get the papers.
Frosty and Kai, thank you for joining the tomato farm!
Thank you!
Go through the city's computers.
Pull up all you can find on Dr. Young.
Alright.
Imprisoned from birth to serve his dead father's sentence, Bane was raised inside the horrific remains of a Santa Prisca prison.
His only friend in the hell hole was a teddy bear named Osito.
Finding solace in smuggled books and meditation, he developed incredible powers of concentration.
When he was subjected to military experience using a steroid code named Venom, his iron-forged will helped him survive when other test subjects had died, and he managed to escape.
Determined to prove his worth, he sought out Batman and broke the Dark Knight's spine.
I feel like... okay.
Like if he knew that worked, why doesn't he just always try to break his spine?
Hehehehe.
Think about it.
Okay, but if you think about it, like you know...
At like... it put him out of commission for a very long time.
So like, it clearly worked.
So like, why doesn't he just keep breaking his spine until he can't walk?
Rage, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Just lurking.
Oh my god, thank you for your first Akasupa slash super chat!
Thank you!
Awesome, welcome!
Thank you for the 10 gifted ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Uh, alright.
But Batman recovered and managed to...
...best Bane.
But like, he never tries to break his spine again!
Cutting off the precious Venom supply, it transforms Bane into... into a superhuman.
He just gave up after the first time.
Went on Venom green.
5'6".
He's 5'6 without Venom?!
Bro!
Hahaha!
Master strategist.
Intense focus.
Abnormally strong reactions.
Determined to best Batman and all the others who's challenged him.
I'll go through anything you find once I get to the cave.
A...Venom?
There's a Batcave here?
It's best to plan ahead for situations like this.
How'd you manage to keep this a secret?
Batman, there's nine nurses and you built a Batcave!
Do you think Dr. Young's been experimenting with animals?
Yes, I'm worried.
Bane seemed even more powerful than usual.
Joker wants the Venom and that can only be trouble.
I'm heading to Dead Man's Point in Arkham North.
I'll contact you once I'm back.
Bane is a short game.
CJ, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Holy shit, X!
Thank you for the 50 gifted ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Oh my god, that's a lot.
Batman, you could have given them free healthcare.
That is so true!
I was like...
There's like so many things wrong with Batman's logic!
This...
The Asylum...
This entire island is run by nine nurses.
Plus like five doctors or some shit.
And then he built a fucking Batcave!
He was like...
What can we do to fix the mental health issues in Gotham City?
Let me build another Batcave.
To like beat up the issue.
Like I don't understand his logic.
More...
Yeah, there's more security than there are nurses.
Oh shit!
Whoops!
Okay, you know what?
Fuck it.
I need XP anyway.
Like it's always nice to have XP.
Oh.
Critical strike.
Nice.
Oh my god, look at how strong I am now.
Ow.
Please!
I'm pressing Y!
Nice.
If I keep pressing Y...
X will die eventually.
Okay.
Come on.
Get over here.
If you solve all the problems...
There will be no need for Batman.
That is actually so fucking dark.
Like...
Like this is just a fucking ego trip for Batman.
You know?
Like he's just like...
He does all of this just to feel good about himself.
Like oh wow.
Not having...
Being a billionaire is just not good enough.
He needs more.
Your appointment?
Very rude.
Well seeing as you're here now, we might as well get started.
Tell me about your childhood.
Anything stand out?
My parents died.
Is that a tear I see?
Too painful?
You'll come back soon.
I'll talk to it later then.
How about baby boy then?
Oh, bet you were shocked to see him...
Well not really.
This is like an asylum for criminals.
I was hoping he'd fold you up like a piece of paper and let me stab you crazy.
But even I don't get everything I want.
So what was he doing here?
Oh, questions, questions, questions.
Well I'm assuming because you wanted to research the venom, right?
Yeah.
If you're researching the venom, then... then like that's why you brought him here?
Because of the doctor?
Alright, here we go.
It's counting you find his work.
Where the fuck is Zask?
Turn around.
Well, too late.
Alright, let's go.
Where am I?
I'm still lost.
Oh shit.
Okay, more XP.
Hello!
I gotta beat you up for XP.
Let's go.
Grab the Bat Crowbar!
Nice.
Wait, do I actually get XP?
I can't tell.
Yes, I do.
Nice.
Easy.
The Bat Crowbar.
Someone was like, no, Batman can't use regular items.
He only uses...
items with the word bat in it.
What's stopping him from fucking dubbing this the crowbar?
Alright, a Bat Crowbar.
Get the Bat Gun!
Well, the door is locked.
Alright.
The fuck?
I guess I have to go all the way backwards?
Oh, I have to go...
Oh my gosh, I have to go like the other way around.
Like, okay.
You know how he's like he can't kill, right?
I can get a Bat Gun and I just shoot the legs.
Like, shoot the foot.
Like, that's all I don't kill.
Like, I feel like giving a minor foot injury is better than brain damage.
It's been a favorite suicide location on Arkham Island for over 100 years.
Yeah, I know.
I once saved an unfortunate inmate from leaping off into the rocks below.
I found a cave entrance...
Okay, sorry Batman.
This is more important.
Upgrades.
Alright, guys.
What do I upgrade next, guys?
What's next?
Sorry.
Sorry for the lore interruption.
What should I get next?
Remote combo throw?
Is the throw actually better?
Okay, I'm gonna get the combo throw.
Let's get a combo throw.
Someone said maybe armor.
Because you almost...
I almost died but, like, I didn't.
Yes, I almost but I didn't.
Twin Batter has...
Because they're cool.
Okay.
Okay, we're not taking advice from the guy that just wants it to look cool.
We're not taking advice from that.
Upgrade the twin... okay.
I'm gonna get the combo there then.
Alright,
let's see.
This way.
Open.
What?
How the fuck do I get out?
Open?
I don't remember.
Oh, it's this way.
TwitterD and TwitterDom saw it.
Can you see it?
Alright, you guys have to help me with these riddles.
I'm not smart enough for this.
Alright, up I go.
Okay, not up, clearly.
Oh, wait, really?
Nice.
He can't use a crowbar, Jason.
We're suffering from PTSD.
He doesn't give a fuck about Jason.
What?
Oh shit, that's a lot of them.
That's okay, free XP.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
God damn it!
I can't believe they would just interrupt me like this!
That's so fucked up.
Alright, nice.
Don't let him hit you.
Why did you do that?
How could you let him hit you like that?
Just dodge, forehead.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Alright, let's see.
If he actually cared about Jason, he would stop getting orphans.
To replace.
That's my hot take.
If he actually cares about them, why are they so easily replaceable?
I don't know.
Alright, let's see.
See-saw by outer gate?
Where the fuck does that mean?
What the fuck?
Where is the other gate?
Here?
All cards, all ID cards are to be shown.
Where is the other gate?
Here?
What does outer gate mean?
North?
West?
Where's north?
Where is north?
Oh!
I figured it out!
Where's the see-saw?
See-saw?
This is north, right?
Oh, there it is!
There it is, I figured it out.
Nice.
Why is there tweedledee and tweedledoo?
That's a real criminal?
That's just Alice in Wonderland.
Cousins with an uncanny resemblance to each other.
Deaver and Dumfreetweet.
Why the f- I feel so bad for these kids.
That's when you know their parents did not love them.
Deaver and Dumfreetweet both shared criminal leanings and a fixation on Lewis Carroll's Alice in Wonderland.
Teaming up, they've modeled themselves after tweedledum and tweedledee from that book.
Planning often outrageous and absurd schemes that trap the- That is their real name.
Wow.
1940- Yeah, that seems like characters made it from 1943.
Oh yeah, the Mad Hatter!
Yeah, I remember the Mad Hatter.
I remember that from Teen Titans.
Do you know about the hidden room later on in the game?
No, this is my first time playing this game.
Thanks for playing one of my favorite games.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Columbus.
Thank you again.
Wait, Jason uses guns?
The fuck?
Batman, you clearly have not taught your robins well.
Wait, the Mad Hatter wasn't in Teen Titans?
Where was he in?
Was he in the Justice League Unlimited?
I swear he was in like one of the TV shows.
Because I like- Unless he was in the comic book series.
I actually own some of the TV shows.
I don't know if it's in the Teen Titans comics.
That was based off the- That was based off the show.
I know that he was from somewhere, but I don't remember.
I remember seeing the Mad Hatter in something.
Where's the Batcave?
I'm literally below it.
Is it like right here?
Locate the cave at- Did I locate it?
Oh, it's there.
Okay, I was gonna be like, where?
Oh my god.
I was like, I- I located it?
Question mark?
I'm Batlost.
I am directionally challenged Batman.
One of my favorite Batman episodes from the anime series.
I don't know which anime series this is.
But like, oh is it the Music Meister?
Only because Neil Patrick Harris.
That's why I had my How I Met Your Mother craze.
Scan the thing beside me?
There's something beside me?
Oh, the Brave and the Bold.
There's so many anime shows that I've like- I have not kept track of like what they're called.
Oh, there is!
The puzzle.
My family's blood ran through the heart of my heart.
We were doctors, politicians, and teachers.
We have been the organ cleaning the arterial filth from the city.
We have been its servants, giving all to protect it.
And still it has chosen to hurt us.
So yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All villains in the game are from the comics except for Harley.
Oh yeah, I know Harley Quinn was invented just for the animated show.
Yeah.
I remember that.
Alright, Apako.
Let's see.
I think like the best DC anime show was 100% of Justice League.
Slash Justice League Unlimited.
I think cause like- I think it aged quite well.
The writing for that show aged incredibly well.
And it was not just for kids, but like adults could watch it too.
Cause it tackled like- It tackled like- It tackled like- Um...
Moments in there that was meant for like- Like even adults could understand.
Like actual real moments.
Like they didn't like pussy out on shit.
I will forever- I will forever associate the voices- Cause like when they like redub Martian Manhunter, I could never- I could never like- Deal with the new voice actors for Martian Manhunter.
Because the only voices I associate with Martian Manhunter was from the Justice League.
Nice, I did it.
God millions- It's not paying taxes.
He does this.
Young Justice was good.
But then every time you reboot a show, It never goes well.
Cause they have to compromise if they're rebooting a show.
And also it takes like a- A couple of years for that to happen.
So like- The story that they wanted to tell was already like, watered down.
Except Samurai Jack?
Okay, remember the ending of Samurai Jack, then say that again.
Looks like she was experimenting on the Arkham patients.
This new chemical only barely resembles the original venom compound.
There are a number of changes that appear to amplify the strength of the drug.
Multiple references to a Titan formula.
Even a small amount could trigger a venom-like transformation in the host, eliminating the need for the storage tank Bane requires.
Hang on, these notes aren't complete.
The formula is missing.
That must be the secret.
The secret Dr. Young is hiding.
If Joker gets his hands on this, he will create an army of a thousand Banes.
Thank God.
Is Joker crazy enough to do that?
What kind of- What kind of- Yeah, it's gonna be like, Barba, what the fuck are you saying?
Is Joker crazy enough to do- Bro!
What?
You should never question about Joker sanity.
Bruce, wait!
Thank you for the 50 gifted chips!
Holy fuck, thank you.
They're appreciated, Bruce Wayne, instead of helping your city.
I mean, you know what?
Fuck it.
That's all right, you don't need to help your city.
Just keep gifting me.
Alright, nice, I upgraded my- my fucking grapplehook.
I'm going after her.
She was heading to the mansion with Cash.
I'm going up top by- Why would Cash have like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like a- like This is like a fucking... phone.
Just be like, Cash don't do it!
She's fucking crazy!
Answer your phone, Cash!
Alright, how do I get out of here?
Is he crazy enough to do it?
If he asks if somebody...
Barbara, bro, she shot... Barbara!
He literally made you paralyzed and you're asking, is he crazy enough to do this?
Alright, so let Batclaw... LT, aim my Batclaw.
But what does the Batclaw do?
Oh, it just moves boxes.
That's stupid!
Whoops!
Sorry.
Oh my god, Batman, these platforms fucking suck.
Alright, let me...
Okay, I didn't realize I had to move all the boxes.
Oh my god.
This Batclaw cost...
$100,000.
What is its purpose?
To remove boxes.
Gator, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, it opens vents too?
Oh, thank fucking god.
Alright.
Alright, $100,000 Batclaw.
So fucking worth.
Why would you hurt me reminding me the ending of Samurai Jack?
Okay, what I hate was that people be like...
But Doki, they like...
They like fixed it in the game.
Yeah, but the game is like mediocre.
It wasn't even like...
The best fucking game ever.
It was like...
Super...
It was like just an average game.
And not everybody fucking...
Plays the Samurai Jack game too.
So it's like...
Yeah, so people were like, there was a game?
Like, I understand why, but it's still...
Doki...
Might as well just put that ending in the actual show.
I'd be scared to criticize Joker.
There was a Samurai Jack game?
Whoa!
I feel like that's like one of Joker's many things.
Like he doesn't kill.
He just does that.
Because like the amount of people he just...
Puts people in wheelchairs.
Is like...
Surprisingly a lot.
It's like...
His like go-to thing.
Where he's like...
Where instead of killing, he just...
Puts them in wheelchairs.
Which IMO is pretty fucked up.
Just like Batman.
Yeah, he does kill.
But then it's like...
It's either kill or wheelchair.
Double tap for it.
This ain't even the main door.
Wrong one.
Wrong one!
I fucking...
I fucking chose the wrong one!
Whoa!
Why is it still not...
Oh wait!
Sorry, I didn't know my left and right.
Sorry!
I pressed...
I pressed left T instead of...
Right T.
Sorry.
I'm still learning my left and right right now.
That makes much more sense actually.
No!
I was about to send your guy to the hospital!
Oh shit.
Oh fuck!
Not a box.
Okay, nice.
No, come on!
How did you bet up?
Okay.
Nice.
I'm currently at work but real quick, I wanna say that I've enjoyed your streams for a while.
You're so infectious when you're feeling joy.
You're truly wonderful.
Thank you Plastergame!
Thank you to Super Chat!
Thank you!
Alright, I think...
I think I need to look at the map real quick.
Oh wait, nice!
I can actually open that now!
Okay.
Oop!
Get over here.
Alright.
Nice.
Oop!
And then...
Yoink!
Mine now!
Yay!
Alright, Riddler!
You don't even have like an actual presence in the game!
If Killer Croc can find love, so can you, Chat.
Woah!
Here you go, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank...
Also, Josh!
Thank you for the 10 gifted ships!
Thank you!
One of Joker's oldest aliases.
So, Joker pays Dr. Young to create his army and then all of a sudden he stops.
Doesn't make any sense.
Open the door behind me?
There's a door behind me?
Here?
Is that Killer Croc?
Guys, I don't know.
The room where it's like glowing?
Also, Sat, welcome to the doke... uh... the tomato farm.
I was gonna say dokey farm.
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Also, I didn't manage to read your super chat, Liga.
The Joker stalked and terrified a dude for cutting him off in traffic.
That's some next level intense right there.
What you didn't know is that, um, he... one... one journalist started criticizing him and then he like told him, he's like, you know what?
You're right, I don't have friends.
You're gonna become my best friend now.
And then he's like, you know what?
I'm your best friend.
And then he like stalked this man for like several years and he wouldn't let him have any friends after that because he was like, you don't need friends.
I am your best friend.
And then he like killed his roommates and also like hurt his wife and everything.
And then... because he was like, you don't need anybody else now.
I'm your best friend now forever and ever.
But yeah, anyway, I don't know about opening this door.
I don't know.
Oh no!
I'm gonna do it.
I shouldn't have done it.
Maybe I shouldn't have done that.
All right nice.
All right we go this way.
Oh more teeth!
Teeth time!
Yes!
Teeth XP!
Teefexp.
Nice.
Alright, door open.
Friendship goals!
No name, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A puzzle has many sides.
And I couldn't read the rest of the riddle.
There's a wall!
I forgot about the wall.
Alright.
I noticed... There's a Riddler trophy!
I'm gonna be 15% done with the Riddler trophies after this.
Alright.
Alright, where's the...
God, I still hate that flashbang.
There's a wall!
I swear I saw... Oh, there it is!
Nice!
Another Riddler trophy!
Okay.
I'm gonna tag the wall real quick.
Gonna do a Banksy.
Boop!
It's a mysterious wall.
Yoink!
Nice.
I'm gonna build over that one.
Where's your 3D model, Riddler?
That's fucking right.
Puzzle, but only some are visible.
Let's see... The Riddler put...
Actually, wait, you're right.
Sounds like she had a change of heart.
She tried to block the payments.
Joker doesn't like it when his partners try to back out.
So he decided to get himself back to our...
Exactly.
I just realized the Riddler has been, like...
placing drywall around the place.
Oh my god, he's even a handyman?
Well...
Wait.
I feel like... Is this...
Oh.
Yeah, I was gonna say...
I was gonna say this is not safe.
This is actually not safe at all.
He had so much free time.
I've hacked into her email accounts.
Wait.
And the second.
A message from Joker,
picture of a dead baby...
Whoa, Joker!
He says, I'm coming for you,
donkey.
No mystery why she's so scared.
Again with the wheelchairs, Joker?!
Payton, thank you the super chat, thank you, thank you.
You're the first streamer I've ever got on my way to watch.
I'm so happy to be a Dragoon.
Love the content, but I'm glad you're heroes.
Thank you the super chat, Payton.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you've been enjoying the content so far.
I told you guys!
It's either kill or wheelchair!
Like Joker!
That's like his whole thing!
He's like, I'm not gonna kill you, but wheelchair.
Alright, let's see this way.
The wheelchair kick is crazy!
Guys, I think the Joker has a problem.
Let's see.
I'll make sure there's nothing here.
Oh, Sonaya, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm just happy to be held back.
Take this red because you're a tomato.
Thank you, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, this way.
There's a light.
There's a lot of wheelchairs in this series.
Oh nice, you're saying we can get over there?
Fuck.
Oh wait.
Wait, what the fuck?
How do I get over there?
Okay, let's get back here.
I'm glad I could like not have to worry about losing... going back from the beginning.
Oh, not yet?
Use the back claw?
I feel like the back claw is not the right way.
Is it... is it actually the back claw?
Can I pull this?
What's the point if I can't pull this?
What if I just pull this wall down?
Need line launcher.
Oh, I don't have that yet.
Okay.
We'll just go.
Oh, teeth.
Okay, I'm gonna make sure there's no fucking drywall again.
That the Riddler put out.
Teeth.
Max, thank you for the ten gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you!
And welcome to the tomato farm, mossy pickles and toaster.
Welcome, welcome.
I'm also Payton.
Alright.
Oh!
Let's see.
No drywall.
Tape patient session two.
Patient name, Waylon Jones.
A.K.A.
Killer Crook.
Poor choice of words.
No one
figured as much.
So, how about this, Doc?
You let me go now, and I won't eat you.
You don't really eat people.
It's just an urban myth.
Oh, you think?
I don't know if you would like to play chicken with, like, a guy that has Killer in his name.
I feel like...
You know, you're like, you don't eat people.
Mr. Killer Crook.
I don't know.
I feel like...
For the sake of your safety...
If this guy's first name is fucking Killer...
I don't know.
I wouldn't fucking try and test that name out.
He kills not eat.
Yes, but...
It's like, similar thing.
Like, you still die.
And she's like, you won't eat me.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Instead of eating, he kills.
Wow.
That is clearly the better alternative.
Vegetarian Croc.
Pacifist Croc.
Alright, let's see.
I feel like...
I shouldn't go over here.
Crocs puts her in the wheelchair.
Alright.
Return to surface via... Oh, I did it.
Yeah.
Ding dong.
Oh.
There's snipers?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, don't climb down.
Oh, shit.
Wow.
Oh, fuck.
You can't.
Oh, shit.
No.
Okay.
Nice.
Did not mean to...
Did not mean to tag the fucking floor.
Where the fuck is the other sniper?
Okay.
That scared the shit out of me.
Oh, there he is.
Sorry.
I panicked.
Oh, my God.
I panicked so hard.
Alright.
Give me a sec here.
Okay.
No way.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
If I just do that.
Can I just...
Okay.
This is fucking useless.
Alright.
Where do I go?
Where is this?
Okay.
Arkham Mansion.
If I keep running...
If I keep running, I'll be safe.
Alright.
Wew.
Okay.
Which way is this?
Alright.
I'll just keep running.
There is no way they can catch me.
Am I going the right...
Okay.
Nope.
I will never go the right way apparently.
If I keep running...
If I keep running, there is no way a bullet is fath...
You know I'm gonna beat up the sniper.
Actually.
Fuck this.
I'm gonna beat up this sniper.
Do I have stamina?
I forgot!
No, this is not a modern game anymore.
Get over here.
Get the fuck over here.
I forgot!
Stamina- Oh shit!
My punch is so strong.
The sheer velocity of my punch fucking hit him.
I forgot.
This game came out like 14 years ago.
So stamina wasn't invented back then.
Alright, how do I get there?
I think that's like the best part.
Like- Oh shit, nice.
The good old days.
Where people were just- were just so good at running.
Legacy of this island has been well and truly buried.
No?
Okay.
Ah shit!
Whoops.
Alright.
Don't worry, I got it.
No!
Nice!
That's fucking right.
The good old days.
Like, I understand they want things to be realistic.
But like, also like, I play video games not for the realism.
I play video games to escape reality.
If I wanna have no fucking stamina, I want no stamina.
It's 14 years ago, games were actually made to be good.
I feel like now games are just made to be like, realistic.
But it's like, I don't want things to be realistic.
They give us a super chat.
Thank you, thank you Breezy.
Should I save them?
Oh, they're dead.
Wait.
Just to be sure.
Oh yeah, they're dead.
Wait!
They disappeared.
Oh my god, where the fuck did the monsters go?
Where the fuck did the people go?
Saved.
Good job, Doki.
You did it.
Oh shit!
What the fuck!
Okay.
Oh my!
Get over here!
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's all about sending a message chat.
Look, I sent a message to that one guy.
As long as that one guy knew what he was saying.
Knew what came.
Knew what went for him.
That's all that matters.
Woooo!
How the fuck can I start hacking?
Okay.
Don't worry, I got this.
Alright.
I'm just gonna fucking beat the shit out of him.
My only solution.
Fucking...
Punch.
Oh shit, that's a wall.
Okay, it's fine.
Get over here.
Alright, nice.
What's over here?
Is this also a hack?
Or can I just bat around this?
Can I?
Oh I... Boom.
Boom.
No I can't.
I have to hack.
Alright.
Well fuck these snipers.
Status deceased.
Oh wait, recording.
I don't think this is a persona.
Bro, you just said you have a girlfriend!
Bro!
No!
The Joker Riz.
I don't know.
I feel like...
I think like...
I don't think you would want to have Joker be infatuated with you.
Because like, he would do some crazy shit just to have your attention.
I'd rather have Joker not be aware of my existence.
Weeeeee.
Or you know, just don't live in Gotham.
I feel like a lot of the criminals, like, Gotham City has all the worst ones.
Like...
Like, not gonna lie.
Ah yes, your friend's gonna die here.
Like...
Of every single criminal, definitely, like, Batman's handling the worst ones.
Alright, nice.
Easy.
Just don't fucking live in Gotham.
Like, okay.
So like, I feel like...
Um...
Out of like, all the most well known DC villains, majority of the most famous DC villains all live in fucking Gotham City.
Like, the Penguin, Bane, Joker, uh...Scarecrow, uh...
Mr. Freeze.
Um... Alright, now think about the Flash villain.
Reverse Flash.
It was me.
I did Barry.
I did all of that.
Alright, yeah.
Poison Ivy, Harley Quinn, Catwoman, Grundy, Two-Face, uh...
Alright.
Superman.
His villain.
Reverse Sup...
What was it?
Reverse Superman.
Lex Luthor.
Who's just like the evil billionaire Batman.
But like, even then, it's like...
It's not as bad as like the Joker.
Like...
Superman.
Lex Luthor.
Um...
Chucking...Bizarre...yeah.
Bizarro.
And he was not even that bad.
And then...
What was it?
Like...General Zod.
Yeah.
And then...Darkseid.
But then like...Okay, Darkseid is like sort of like the Thanos of DC.
But even then, he just shows up like once every fucking five years.
Joker is every day.
Anyway...
What I'm saying is that...I don't know.
Maybe we should stop living.
Maybe Batman is outrageously terrible at his job.
If like 80% of the most well-known villains live in Gotham City.
And me.
Bam!
Oh shit.
Alright.
There has to be like a place to grapple, right?
Owning real estate in Metro City is a bad idea.
Wait, what?
I guess we have to like go up?
Anton.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But don't you forgot Captain Code.
A man who best splashed with a hand-held refrigerator.
I feel like it has to be...Oh, there it is.
I see it.
Is that a vent?
Alright, now I have to go back.
Use detective mode.
Wait, that's a vent, right?
Oh shit.
Clayface is also Gotham City!
You're just making me more right!
Alright,
nice.
I'm here now.
Alright.
Nice.
Door open.
He just walked away!
Okay, we have to kick the one with the gun.
Wheee!
Oh my God!
It's like it came from a mile away!
Nice.
Countered.
That's fucking right!
BAM!
Hospital bills!
I guess I was like, but what about Cyborg Superman?
Who knew about Cyborg Superman?
More people know who the fuck the Riddler is!
The fucking cyborg Superman!
Who the fuck is Cyborg Superman?
That was the first time I even heard about Cyborg Superman!
Alright.
I had to tab out because my chat died.
Me.
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay, Dr. Young.
Okay, it has to be like here.
Let's see if there's anything I have to find out.
If I remember correctly, the reason why that Gotham's criminals always got out of Arkham was due to this warden, Hugo Strange.
Who purposely let them loose to study Batman.
And this is also Batman's problem!
He funded- He fucking funded Arkham Asylum!
So like...
Isn't that his fault?
For like, hiring practices?
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like, they could literally just have like an inspection to make sure there's no corruption r- Cause like, wouldn't Batman be like, That's weird.
Why are the criminals keep escaping almost every day?
Surely the justice system isn't corrupt because of that.
Maybe it's just very unlucky that they keep fucking escaping Arkham Asylum.
Like, I- World's greatest detective, my fucking ass.
Claire, thank you for the 20 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Damn, that's fucking crazy that people keep escaping.
That's so crazy.
Oh shit, look, wheelchair.
Oh no.
No, he brought it to work.
What do I do here?
Detective moding right now.
This is where- Isn't this where- Oh, there's a vent up here.
Okay.
There.
Run!
There's a wheelchair!
The Joker is near!
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
We gonna
Oh!
I remember there was, like, in the comic where Superman kills the Joker, and then Batman was like.
There was, like- Batman was like- I think that's, like, one of my favorite, like, illustrate- I think that's one of my favorite, like...
one of my favorite scenes because Batman is just like.
Cause he's like, you can do that?
Because he's like, you can do that?
Batman did that right?
Is this Mr. Freeze?
No, no, because it's a scarab.
Because it feels like the body thing, but then I'm not sure because it's a scarab.
But yeah, if you guys didn't know that, that Injustice, Superman, it's where basically it's like evil, the evil league or whatever.
And then it's so fun, there's like a comic scene of the illustration of Superman killing Joker.
And I just love Batman's face.
I just love Batman's face in that because it's just so fucking stupid.
It's just...
Who is the main man in the main hall?
Him?
This guy?
Who else would it be?
I need to make sure there's like nothing here.
Oh shit, that's a lot of people here.
Whoops.
I was like, let me make sure there's nobody here.
What the fuck?
What am I supposed to do?
Oh wait, upgrade time.
Alright.
Let's see.
What do we upgrade, guys?
Guys, what do we... Oh wait, I can do that?
A and X.
Oh my god, I've just been pressing X this entire time.
Okay, powerful Batarang.
Alright, let's see.
Remote Batarang is really fun.
Okay, we'll try that.
Remote Batarang.
Okay, upgrade it.
Alright, how do I do this?
Alright.
Whoops.
How do I...
How do I fucking do that?
How do I control it?
I'm so confused.
Oh shit.
How do I...
But how do I control it?
Fucking hell no!
How do I...
Switch.
Oh, I have to select it?
Oh!
Okay.
My experiment.
Oh shit, okay.
This is a lot harder.
Give me a...
Give me a sec.
This is actually... I need to charge it?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
World's greatest detective.
Also Batman.
Just one more trip to Asylum.
It'll work this time, I swear.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
Okay, that's pretty funny.
I'm just gonna chuck this.
I don't...
And then I want... It'll eventually die.
Fuck this one guy in particular.
Wait, can I actually kill him?
There's no way.
Okay, no way.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Alright.
There we go.
Alright, I'm just gonna fucking kill him.
Yeah!
Boop!
There we go.
Okay, how do I throw you?
I need to throw you.
Please!
I need to throw you!
Let me throw you!
No!
It won't let me throw you!
Ow.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Get over here.
Give me that free fucking juicy XP.
I didn't eight combo?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Don't worry, I'm getting it.
Yes!
Let me throw!
Alright, now I'll never do that again.
That aim!
Thank you!
It's a great aim right there.
Thank you, the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Nice.
I'll never have to throw again after that.
Use the bat, bat.
Alright, easy.
Oh yeah, that was easy.
Okay.
Let's...
Let's grab...
the Riddler thing here.
I need that XP.
More wheelchairs.
Alright.
Give me.
Okay.
Let's see.
I need to make sure...
Alright.
What was up this riddle?
Oh, hey, teeth.
Teeth.
Alright, what's the answer to this riddle, guys?
Riddle me this.
So many, like, areas to...
Alright, open.
What's this?
Oh, another tape.
Whoa!
Oh, he's doing his own interview?
Oh!
What a plot twist.
Oh, that was the scarecrow!
Okay, it's still underneath the statue?
What does that even mean?
Oh my god, look at all these bodies.
Also, like, it's not great that they passed out, too.
That just means, like...
Like, it's, like, even worse.
Okay, no, not that.
No, not that.
No, not him.
That's a gargoyle?
I'll never figure out.
I'll never figure it out, apparently.
Let's see.
Is there anything I'm missing?
I don't know.
Just need to make sure I'm not missing anything.
Ah, shit, more TVs.
Left?
The west wing.
Nope, not that.
Wait, there's a scare up there.
Density unknown?
Nope, not that.
It's in the side hall.
The fuck is a side hall?
What the fuck is a side hall?
This hall wing?
Did you see it?
I'm just gonna grab these teeth.
It's a hall on the side.
Thanks, guys.
Oh my god, this fucking tooth.
Alright, nice.
Can I just open this door?
That's it?
It's just for the teeth?
Let's see.
Where do I go from here?
I can't get through from here.
Because all the area is locked.
Huh.
Where the fuck do I go?
Straight ahead to the left?
Wait, okay, what's the map?
Oh, there's a door!
Wait, there's a door right here.
I can open doors.
Oh, there it is!
The side hall!
Arrest recognition award for your outstanding contribution.
Well, to be fair, if they keep getting out, you can always keep arresting.
Like if you think about it.
Easy, isn't it?
Well, we'll see.
We'll see.
Oh my god, we found it.
It was the hall on the side.
What does a bird need in the rain?
I don't know.
Okay.
Cover?
Let me make sure that...
Alright, there is one person here.
An umbrella.
I mean, everybody needs an umbrella.
Why is it just a bird?
Boop.
Destroyed five joker teeth.
I'm pretty sure I destroyed more.
Aim and throw well-being scene when you're in the corner cover.
Okay, watch this.
Okay.
Maybe he knew what was coming.
Maybe...
Watch this.
The third has brought someone in to deal with it.
...I don't mean a talk.
Would have been fun.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
Oh, it's a penguin!
Riddle me this.
I totally knew that.
No!
I got the gun!
It's okay, I got the gun guys.
It's okay, he's not gonna pick up the gun.
He's not smart enough for that.
He's not smart enough.
It was so close!
What do you mean?
I almost got it!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If Doki got hit with the Scarecoast Nightmare Gas, she could hallucinate a giant map.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How was I supposed to know?
Okay.
I'll paint that.
Nice.
What's in here?
Oh, it's just this.
It's another chronicle.
Yeah, I was gonna say, whenever they're like, I'm eager to see my family, they're never alive.
Poor guy, he lost his family.
Oh hey, what's this?
Alright, pull that down.
Pull that down.
It's in one of the cases?
Where the fuck is the umbrella?
Is it... no?
Where's the umbrella?
Okay, that's not an umbrella.
Where the fuck is the umbrella?
Oh, there it is!
Shit, that's a lot of umbrellas.
Nice.
Riddle solved.
The Penguin.
One of Batman's oldest foes.
Is an eccentric criminal mastermind.
Known as much for his love of ornithology and trick umbrellas.
As for shady business dealings.
Gotham's popular Iceberg Lounge serves as Cobblepot's front for a number of illegal financial activities.
That fund much of the city's underworld.
Despite his short stature, the Penguin is a wildly foe whose umbrellas conceal a variety of deadly weapons and gadgets.
Oswald Chesterfield Cobblepot.
I like how this one's not a professional criminal.
He's just like a restaurant owner.
No big deal.
He's just...
Okay, that is... there's no way he's 5'2".
I'm 5'2".
There's no fucking... he's lying about his height.
There's no way.
Because if Batman is 6 feet...
You think about it.
Okay, Bruce Wayne.
Where's Bruce Wayne?
Where the fuck is Bruce Wayne?
I refuse to...
There's no fucking way.
Bruce Wayne is 6'2".
Okay, if you imagine 5'2".
Like, it's not like... okay.
Oh, it counts the top hat?
Okay.
That makes more sense now.
Because I was like, there's no fucking way.
This guy is 5'2".
When like, every time you put him next to the...
Penguin... like, if you put him next to the Batman.
He's like... he reaches his like, Batman's crouch or something.
And I'm like, there's no fucking way.
A 5'2 prince will feel like that short.
You guys are like...
Doki, that's some sick copium right now.
I refuse to believe that that's a 5'2".
There's no fucking way.
I refuse to believe it.
That's just too sad.
Oh, hey guys.
Let me go back outside.
Doki, go.
Why is it up here?
I'm like, trying to think.
Okay, I'm just gonna beat people up here.
Wait, I'm just gonna make sure there's no...
Um...
What?
Oh, I have to open the door.
I wanna make sure there's no guns.
No guns?
No guns.
Okay.
Well, I don't really care.
I'm just gonna beat them up.
Yeah!
Oh shit.
I really don't care.
Okay.
Oh shit!
There's so many people!
It's okay.
I'm good.
Nice.
You're all stunned.
No!
Counter!
Okay, stunned.
Nice.
If all else fails, just keep pressing X.
And sometimes Y.
Six and Black, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh no, I got... made him back up.
Who needs stealth when I can just stealth them with my fists?
You can just stroll downstairs and save the helpless hostages.
Right?
There's hostages here?
Oh shit!
That's clearly not caring about that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't know Burnt Doki comes in penguin size.
The only way I could have made that one easier to find is if I strapped into the hood of that ludicrously ostentatious beast.
I'm not sure if that's the right word.
Alright, let's make sure that there's no other criminals around.
That's what I'm saying!
That's why I'm like, there's no way...
There's no way Penguin is five foot two.
He's lying about his fucking height.
I'm basically correct!
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I was like, I'm gonna cut the chandelier.
Why don't they cut the chandelier?
Oh shit, two minutes?
Wait, does it count?
Let's try to figure out how to do the chandelier!
Oh god.
Oh god, don't do well under pressure, Joker!
Joker!
Never do well under pressure!
Oh god.
Oh god!
Oh god, okay.
Okay, I need to be in detective mode.
I can think better.
I don't even know if it's time yet!
What do I do?
Cutting!
Cut!
Gotta say, I'm getting bored already.
Maybe I should just pass the buck.
Boo.
What do I do?
I'll be joking.
Oh, there it is!
Open.
Do not open before... Okay.
Thank you, Batman.
Are they all gone?
Yes, you're safe.
What happened?
It all happened so fast.
Some patients broke in, began tearing up the place, like they were looking for something.
Bill here fought back, but there were too many.
They took Dr. Young.
She rushed in here and they followed.
I'm sorry.
When I came to, we were all tied up.
Doc Young was gone.
You're not a doctor, you're a guard!
Factory, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the fun stream and funny moments.
Keep your head up, Doki.
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
I'm glad you've been enjoying the stream!
Oh my god.
Alright, guys.
I need help.
How do I solve... Riddle me this.
How do I solve this?
It was like something out of thin air.
Riddle me this.
What the fuck does that mean?
Do not open before April 1st.
Love, Joker.
No clue.
There's a book.
There's so many books.
Whoa!
Maybe this?
Open door?
No, that's where I came from.
This Finnish puzzle.
The library.
Oh, wait!
There's no puzzle here.
Look at the map.
Oops.
This?
Oh, there's a sitting... Wait.
Did I go in that hidden room yet?
Can't tell.
There's a book in the library.
There is?
I think it has to be above.
Oh, hey.
There's another... Wait.
I didn't see this.
What's this?
Oh, in the previous room.
It's okay.
I needed this anyway.
I need the riddler trophy.
Alright.
Down I go.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Where is the door?
Fuck.
I'm so fucking lost.
I'm so...
There's two riddles in here?
Joker... riddler!
Why did mom let you have two riddles?
There is?
There's no book here.
Readings for losers.
What?
Where the fuck is the book?
I'm gonna go up here just in case.
Look to my left.
Guys, don't you guys remember that like... I don't know my left and my right?
There is a question mark.
Fuck.
Okay.
This is a little embarrassing.
Oh!
There it is!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
I must be able to...
Alright.
Oh!
Fuck!
Not the floor!
Wait.
It doesn't matter?
What do you mean perspective?
Like this?
Oh!
What the fuck do you mean?
Grapple on the vent and do the perspective.
Alright.
We got this.
Like that?
That's not a line.
What the fuck?
Go higher?
I'm already as high as I can be.
Okay.
Maybe...
God damn it!
Sorry.
I'm too stupid for this.
Are you fucking...
Are you fucking serious?
There's a dot next to my feet.
There's a dot next to my...
Oh!
I figured it out.
It's like I'm standing it this entire time.
Oh my god.
I didn't realize I was standing on the fucking dot.
I was like what the fuck do you mean there's a dot next to my feet?
I'm... Whoa!
Yes.
XP time.
Thanks Joker for sending me more experience points.
Boom.
Concussion time.
World's greatest detective by the way.
That's me!
That's me guys.
Do you guys know?
I am the world's greatest detective.
I'm just wondering...
Where do I go now?
Because like this door is still locked.
Biggie.
Biggest brain moment.
Go back to the library?
Where's the library?
Did I go back?
Did I went the wrong way?
Please don't tell me they're back already.
The south corridor.
There's another door?
How did I miss the other door?
Oh wait.
Because I'm blind.
That's it.
Oh there is another door.
Right here.
No!
Stop tagging your signature!
There you go.
God damn it.
Just gonna make sure.
Just gonna make sure I don't miss anything.
Wait no.
I was here.
Batman was here.
Where's the map?
Where did I not go?
Chat lied.
God damn it chat!
Where do I go?
Oh my god.
God fucking...
Okay I guess...
I guess I leave?
Where do we top up the tower?
Okay.
Don't believe our lies.
Back to the main hall.
God fucking damn it.
I knew it.
I knew you guys were fucking with me.
Go to the north corridor.
The main hall.
Where's north?
North is up.
Is this north?
Don't believe their truths either?
But there's a door?
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
Bam!
Nice.
What?
Wait what?
What's that collar do?
Why is it making that noise?
It's the suicide collar.
But it sounds weird.
Suicide collar?
What?
Well they've got some other name but well we just use them to monitor patients heartbeats.
If it drops too low the alarm goes off and a crash team rushes in.
Wait I killed?
What's that?
How do you like that?
Apple's bath?
Standing around in the...
Let's see...
Ah, the west wing...
Oh this is definitely not north.
They'd be here now if they weren't busy knocking a little cents into cash.
I'll tell you what.
I won't spoil the surprise and let them know you're coming.
Wait did I kill?
Did I kill?
Oh hey upgrade.
Alright.
It's upgrade time guys.
What are we getting?
I think it's a box.
Alright, I am never... guys, all I know is that...
is that it was a mistake to listen to you guys when you said remote BATTERAD.
Oh wait, no upgrades, never mind.
All I'm saying was that the remote BATTERAD was not helpful.
It's not because I can't aim, alright?
I'm just gonna let you guys know.
It's not because it was me.
It's not a me issue, okay?
It is... it is not a me issue.
I just want you guys to know that.
It is not a skill issue!
I don't know why...
It says like a structural weak... oh wait, look.
Security, okay I can't get there yet.
And I can't do that yet either.
I guess I'll open the door?
Oh!
That's a lot of... that's a lot of guns.
Can I?
Boop!
Hello.
Oh, I guess like... it can be used to...
Uh...
Come on, come on, come on.
No!
It was so close!
What if I just do this and then I...
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, that's awkward.
That is so awkward.
Alright, come over here.
Come over here.
Come on!
Okay, but what...
What if...
Oh my god, there's way too many people here.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
This is what we do.
There's no way I...
Okay.
What did I do?
You still came from over there.
There's no way I could fuck this up, guys.
Whooooooa!
Bam!
I told you!
I told you there was no way I could fuck this up!
I wonder if he can pick up his gun again.
I wanna know if he can pick up his gun.
Can he pick up his gun?
Okay, let's just go glad kick him.
Boom.
Okay.
Making sure...
Keep quiet!
Nice.
Whoooooo!
Oh shit!
No way he knows!
There's no way he knows!
There's no way!
Okay.
Wait!
Maybe it is good!
Oh wait!
I didn't realize I could do get triple kill!
Whoooooooa!
I didn't realize it was bullying!
If I knew it was bullying...
Alright, whoever... whoever fucking suggested the remote control batarang...
You were right.
Oh boy, a trippa!
Thanks.
Where did Dr. Young go?
I told her to run.
These guys came in looking for her.
I told her to go to her office and hide.
Does she keep her records there?
I guess.
She was pretty desperate to get in there.
Her office is over there.
How long ago was this?
I need to find her notes before Joker gets his hands on them.
20 minutes, maybe more.
I really hate the bat suit that he's wearing.
His ears are too long!
Like, I just wanna...
Not a problem.
I wanna grab a pair of scissors.
And just cut it.
Okay, investigate Dr. Young's location.
I just don't like how fucking...
Short... long it is.
I just wanna grab a pair of scissors and just go snip snip.
Alright, this way.
It would be better if it was just Mr. Mad.
Go mad or was he just dizzy?
Going after the notes yourself, eh, bat?
That's fucking right, Joker.
I've got a crew working over the daughter as I speak.
Yeah, but your crew is just like... criminals.
Like... like the jockeys.
They're not scientists.
Not a net, a body of clouds ripping the...
Never, Joker!
Because I have too much money to stop now!
This is literally just my hobby.
Hey, teeth.
Nice.
I only destroyed ten?
I feel like I destroyed so many.
Alright, what?
That's it?
Where'd I go?
Justin, welcome to Tomato Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Oh, hey.
What?
I feel like this is a...
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Oh, it's him!
Alright.
Oh, he's a crazy guy.
Founded the Elizabeth Arkham Asylum for the criminally insane.
Naming it after his...
Oh my god, why would you name that after your mom?
Oh, that's why.
Who he euthanized as treatment for dementia.
Building it on the old grounds of his family historic mansion on the outskirts of California.
Got them.
Personally treated his first patient, Martin Mad Dog Hawkins.
But killed the wife and daughter.
After administering fatal electroshock treatment to Hawkins, he lost all grip on his sanity and was admitted into his own institution.
Oh shit, how tall is he?
The most important information I need to know.
How tall was he?
Alright, nice.
Is it?
This is where I... Oh wait, no.
This is...
different.
God, there's so many vents and everything.
Nice.
Riddle me this.
Go!
Welcome to Jemaya Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Alright, down I go.
Too unarmed.
Oh, there he is.
I was like, what the fuck?
And... boop!
Alright.
Oh no, let me make sure he doesn't pick up his gun again.
That's fucking right.
Dodge this!
My fucking fist!
I have too much money!
Ow.
The little fucking...
The little fucking slap.
Nice.
It was that easy.
Punch it.
Oh my god, wait!
Okay, but why can't I just blow it up with my fucking...
Bata explosion?
Like, there's no way it only works on drywall.
That's so fucking stupid.
Why can't I just blow it up?
Because it's not that strong.
Fucking weak.
What's the point of having explosives if they're weak as fuck?
I have so much money!
It's anti... it is anti-drywall explosion.
Scan the body?
Really?
Hey, those bodies don't matter.
Oh, these bodies?
That's a cold day in hell when this...
Oh wait, is that Raul Gull?
That's him?
Little is known of the early years of the...
That's your future...
Uh...
Father-in-law.
Whose name means the demon's head.
But it's known that he has lived for many centuries due to Lazarus Pith's mystical and alchemical bruise that restored his youth.
A brilliant master of strategy and organization.
Uh, Raul Gull's goal is to save the Earth from ecological devastation by destroying most of its population.
He recognized Batman as both a wealthy foe and a possible ally.
Except that Batman cannot escape his dystopian worldview.
Batman also shares his love-hate relationship with Raul's daughter.
The beautiful Talia.
You know, like...
I would never understand why Batman is like...
Ageless.
But like his robins grow up.
I find that like...
Really weird.
Like...
Like I understand they don't want him to like...
Age.
Because then like...
Cause he's Batman.
So they can use him forever.
But like...
All his like adopted sons and daughters like...
Age with him.
And then like at one point Dick Grayson is now like sort of the same age as Batman.
If you think about it.
Because like if he's like 20...
If Dick Grayson is like 20 and 30.
Then how old is fucking Batman at that point?
He would be like...
60 or something.
But he's not.
Like if you think about it.
That's why I don't understand.
I don't understand why like...
Just don't age.
But I guess they're like we need more robins.
We need more robins!
We can't keep having them!
We can't keep having Dick as a robin!
Cause I don't...
We hate calling him Dick.
He's been in the pit.
Like it's understandable like Superman's aged this.
Cause he's a fucking alien.
The doctor?
The surfer Richard?
Yeah but he's still...
Everyone still calls him fucking Dick.
It's like he doesn't take the  for being Desktop...
Here comes the next stop sign.
Now we have 3 sleep He's sleeping?
Shut up!
Turn if off!
Push
them all!
Push them all!
Huh?
What do I have to press?
Oh, finish this mission first.
I don't know where he wants me to look at.
The cameras?
Oh, here.
Oh, the safety deposit.
Okay.
Whoops.
Scanning.
It has to be here.
Oh, shit.
Okay, now I can scan.
No.
Now I can scan.
Nice.
Yay!
Whoops.
Following the suspicious death of this man, his multi-million parents... Oh my god, how many...
Okay, there's a lot of millionaires.
But how many millionaires live in fucking Gotham?
Like...
Inherited their fortune and then went on to bankrupt their company.
Saved by a buyout by Bruce Wayne, he came to resent and hate Wayne.
Oh my god, everyone hates him because he just spends money, I guess.
Fixated on the concept of masks, he carved one from his family's black coffin and sell it revenge.
His ensuing battle with the Dark Knight caused him as the...
Caused his mask to be burnt into his skin, remaking him as the Black Mask.
He is now a feared gang leader and one of the most powerful mod bosses in Gotham.
A burning hatred of Batman.
Bro, like, everybody hates him.
Get in line!
Get in fucking line!
Everyone hates him!
You're not special!
I forgot what upgrade you guys wanted.
What was the upgrade you wanted?
Wait, his height!
Wait!
Doki, you have to look at his height!
Okay, what do we upgrade first?
Takedown?
Instant Takedown?
Is this it?
Special Combo Takedown.
It's not available yet.
Unless it's in another one.
Armor upgrade?
Nope.
Better at Power.
Not available.
Where the fuck is the Instant Takedown?
Auto Proximity...
It is?
Lock in your...
Oh, is this...
Takedown...
Oh!
Okay, I didn't see that.
Okay.
Whoops.
BNY.
Alright, nice.
Okay, now I can open doors.
No.
Okay, apparently not.
Not that we go through.
Apparently not, guys.
Where did I come from?
It's just like, where am I?
Alright, here we go.
Alright, don't worry.
I want to see your faces when I beat the shit out of you.
Bam.
It's alright.
I love pressing spamming X.
It's my favorite part.
That's fucking right.
You thought you can beat me up?
You're just goons.
You're not special.
You don't even have names.
Get out of here.
His height...
We'll never know.
We'll never know his height.
Alright.
It's gonna be a mystery forever.
Oh, I forgot this one, T.
Where's the records office?
This way?
The tape.
Go back.
I missed the tape.
It wasn't tape.
I was too busy beating people up.
Oh, there it is.
I feel like Bruce should spend more money on the mental health situation here.
Is there like a multiverse where Bruce Wayne actually spends his money on fixing the mental health issues in Gotham rather than beating up mentally ill people?
I didn't think about it.
I just realized, wouldn't it be better to fund research on like...
I mean, I feel like he didn't try that hard.
I feel like beating up people is sort of like the last resort.
If you think about it.
I feel like... I don't know.
It doesn't feel like he tried all that hard to fix the issue.
You raised more money for mental health in 24 hours than Bruce Wayne did in his whole career.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Prince thank you for the magenta soup.
Hey Toge.
Glad to see you are enjoying this game.
I used to play it when I was a kid.
Can't believe how old it looks now compared to when it came out.
Thanks for the fun stream.
I recently lost my Oshi and these are keeping me alive.
Thank you for the money.
Thank you!
I'm glad you've been enjoying it.
Thank you.
I thought you guys said go to the library.
Is this not the library?
Is this not the fucking library?
Guys, I think I got baited.
I think I got baited.
Find a book.
Oh, is it book time?
Is this it?
Is this not the library?
But there's books!
There's more than one library?
Guys, there's more than one library?
Why the fuck did we fund all these libraries for?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, fingerprints.
Fingerprints.
Okay, I found the fingerprints.
Okay.
And then the trail disappears?
Alright.
Where the fuck are the prints?
I followed it!
I followed all the fingerprints!
That- the two fingerprints!
I mean, Harleen Quinzel was a psychiatrist.
And look where she ended up.
Uh, the- uh, the junkie.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, but then that- they gotta hire people outside of Gotham City!
Why are we still hiring doctors in Gotham City?
They're clearly not reliable!
Okay, it's the bottom floor.
Oh, there it is.
I didn't realize it was like super close.
Oracle, I found Dr. Young's formula.
Great.
So does that mean you've stopped Joker?
You never stopped Joker.
What do you mean?
It's never this simple with him.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
What's that you've got there?
He
was acting out some twisted fantasy.
Maybe he could get her talking?
I think he probably can!
Great!
What?
Rescue Dr. Young from Zass in the warden's office?
Wait, is that gas?
Not good.
Okay, we gotta go back.
Oh, that's not good.
Well, let me leave those two back there.
Sucks to be those...
Oh no, I missed the scarecrow gas.
It's the scarecrow gas.
God damn it.
I still left those two people there, so...
Sucks to be those two.
Oh no, it's the crime alley.
Alright, time to relive trauma.
This is where you're...
Oh shit!
Wait, it's actually called crime alley?
I thought that was a joke!
It's like a joke in Teen Titans!
And like...
Wait!
Okay...
The wave valley is actually stupid as fuck.
If you are like, multi-billionaires, you would not go down crime alley.
Like...
That's just like...
That's actually just fucking stupid.
Like, I thought that was a joke.
I didn't realize it was actually called crime alley.
I'm tired.
Can't we just wait for him here?
Come on, keep up.
We're nearly there.
Alright, here we go.
Down in crime alley!
Here we go!
Self-fulfilling prophecy!
Stay where you are.
I'll shoot.
I'll give you whatever you want.
Oh!
Did
we die in crime alley?
It's true, that's crime-yally.
Hahaha!
Um...
Doki, it's Latin.
Why?
Crime alley was supposed to be safe!
Oh, there's my bat.
My bat signal.
Oh, I can move?
No.
Jesus.
You better just get the bat.
I mean, money can not fix trauma.
Whatever you say, Gordon.
His butler is on his way to pick him up.
You hear that?
He's got a hot puff.
Bro, that's fucked up.
Wait, what is...
I mean, there's no blood!
I just need to ask you some questions.
Can I get you anything?
I'm a tiny little boy.
You don't feel like answering me, but it's the only way to catch you did this.
I don't know.
It's a cut.
Whoa!
I look back and I'm like, oh, my parents are okay.
Alright.
Alright, so that was James Gordon.
Oh no, back to the scarecrow we go.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go again.
There is he.
Whoa!
He's back!
I thought I beat the shitter out of you.
Okay.
Okay, I can hide here.
Nice.
I can keep running.
I can- NOOOO!
Fuck!
Okay.
Alright, use the black- OHHHH!
The back cloud to create new cover!
Okay, I didn't realize you could do that.
Fuck!
Sorry, I got a little impatient.
I got a little impatient.
I thought I could run fast!
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, now I know.
Whoa!
Here we go.
What did I- Okay, okay, I was gonna say.
I was worried that like...
Uhh...
I was worried that like me pulling it down would also trigger him.
I like all these different mechanics though.
Cause it's not- It doesn't- It's not just one thing.
Alright, run, run, run, run, run.
They were murdered by Joe Chill?!
That's just sad.
Oh!
Nothing?
It was nothing?
Oh shit.
Alright, I can beat up the skeletons.
Sorry!
Okay, it's a little funny to see a skeleton try to sucker punch me.
It's a little quirky there.
Yeah, you got a little bit of no chill.
Also, they're billionaires.
Why are they watching a movie with the public?
I bet you they have their own home theater.
Wouldn't they have their own home theater?
Okay.
I wanna know how this is gonna go back and forth.
Okay, what if they just wanna live a normal life?
Alright, you don't understand.
They wanted to know what it was like out there.
Like the common folk.
Alright, let's see.
It wasn't a theater.
It was like a movie.
Unless they retconned that again.
Oh god.
No!
I jumped the wrong way!
It was the opera?
I thought it was movie theater.
Unless it got retconned.
I went the wrong way.
I swear to god.
At one point, it was a movie.
Yeah, it was the movie.
Okay, they retconned it so many times that it stopped making sense.
This is why the comic industry is dying.
Because they keep... they retcon... like... oh my god, please.
They retconned so many times that like... that like it's just hard to like keep up with anything.
And they rebooted so many fucking times.
Like it's just... it's just a headache.
Because you guys were like, no, it's the opera.
And I was like, it was the opera?
I thought it was the movies.
Okay, well, I guess I'm not gonna get off the pillar.
I can't get off of it.
Alright,
move on the other side.
Okay.
Nice.
They got us.
Please let me go.
Alright, give me the skellies!
Give me the skellies!
Get over here.
Get the fuck over here.
I just love how they have the...
They even have the...
They have crowbars.
You think that's gonna kill me?
You have no muscle on those bones!
Alright, nice.
I got a bone to pick with you.
Hello, Mr. Bones.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, climb.
Oh, RB.
Okay.
Oh, there's no...
I don't think there's... Okay, yeah, there's here.
Can you stop looking?
Where is he looking at?
I can't tell.
No, thank you for the aca soup!
Thank you, thank... What?
No!
Oh my god, but it's an aca, aca, aca, aca soup!
It was worth it.
Thank you for the aca, aca, aca, aca soup.
I made it.
There you go.
It was totally worth it.
I can get there.
I can get there before he looks at me!
Nice.
The scarecrow hired them.
I'm here.
Anyone?
No?
No.
That's good.
Zazz has Dr Young trapped in the warden's office.
I've got to get out of here.
How do I get out of here?
Am I stuck here?
Do I...
Wait.
Okay.
I didn't think I could break that rope because it's a pretty thick rope.
Broke.
Yay!
Who needs to tell time?
I'll just fix it with money later.
Yay!
Property damage does not matter for me.
Alright.
Oh hey, the bridge is fixed.
Or like, not the bridge, the gates.
Oh my god, wait, yeah!
Property damage does not fucking matter!
Because like, I'm so fucking rich, I...
If I break property, I can just fix it with money!
A game of cat and mouse can be painful.
Okay.
Let's see.
That's my superpower.
I'm just gonna fucking beat him up.
Oh shit!
You know what?
I can take him.
Alright.
That's fucking right.
Boom!
That's- Oh shit!
Okay.
What?
Alright.
Come on.
There we go.
Wait, how do I kill him then?
How do I kill him?
Do I just...
Oh!
Okay.
That was easy.
Nice.
Sorry, how do I...
Make sure he just doesn't...
Get up.
But like, still be alive.
All of us.
My great father...
I'm going to be like...
Well, that's my way of saying...
Bye!
Well, let's go.
I got some of that.
Uh...
I don't want to be like...
I'll tell you what, I think that this is awesome.
I don't know why but...
No!
What.
I'm gonna die!
I won't die!
I'll kill you!
I don't know what.
I don't know.
Oh no!
Maybe... is there... let me... this?
Wait a minute.
Oh no, that's just the bathroom.
Sir, I would like to use the bathroom real quick.
Not the ears!
But what about all the wheelchairs?
The ears!?
Joker!
That is a waste of a perfectly good wheelchair!
Servers!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome Welcome!
Is that everything?
I thought there would be an actual...
I felt like there would be an actual trophy here.
Servers, thank you for 10 gifted shards!
Thank you- Thank you!
The fuck?
What's the point of going in here?
There's no trophy?
I feel scammed.
I can't believe there was no trophy.
Hello?
Who the fuck is this guy?
Is that Zazz?
Don't worry, I'm coming over!
Oh shit.
If you had arranged a murder, I would show the more of a doctor.
I'm sorry!
The trophy was right there!
Who are you?
Playing you like a violin and cutting your strings?
But the trophy...
No, you don't understand!
The trophy was right there!
Listen to me carefully.
Help me!
What is happening out there?
I'm coming over.
Come any closer.
Help me!
No!
Who the fuck is this?
Who do you think is arranging a murder?
What is going on?
I crouched on everything!
I'm too lazy.
Playing you like a violin and cutting your strings?
I don't understand!
I even crouched!
Listen to me carefully.
Help me!
What is happening out there?
I guess I'll help.
Come any closer.
I'm sorry!
The trophy was so dis... No!
Give me my trophy!
I know.
Joker threatened me.
I wanted to stop the experiment.
I tried to give him his money back.
You don't just give back money from... Yeah, you don't just give back money from... He doesn't give a fuck about money!
You think he cares about money?
So now he has venom.
End your formula.
God, I hate his ears.
I want to like just cut his ears off.
There's a lamp hidden in the gardens.
It's locked off, but the security key codes for the entire island are in the warden's safe.
What else?
It's just in the warden's safe?
Everything?
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
Yeah, I thought it was just obviously a bomb.
I feel like he'd see the Joker's face first.
Like the spray paint.
Oh!
He needs to watch.
Oh shit, there he is.
Wait, what about the doctor?
Is he okay?
All right, nice.
All right, as long as the fucking guy with the shocker doesn't get near me, it's fine.
Let me get this guy out real quick.
Okay, get out of here.
Oh shit, no.
Get out of here.
Let me kill this guy first.
God damn it, get out!
Leave me alone!
Okay, there we go.
Let me just run around him.
Reggie, thank you for the five Kimious!
Thank you!
Mecca he's not going anywhere!
He's already got out twice tonight.
Thank you for the super shot.
Thank you.
Oh shit, she's dead?!
Oh, she's dead!
I was like, where is she?
Oh, you mean the body part that's surrounded by blood?
Blood?
Where could she be?
Sorry, I didn't notice that was actually her.
Nice.
Oh shit, what's this?
Oh, there's a secrets map.
Nice.
Apparently there's a secret room?
She was not bombproof?
There's no fucking way.
Oh hey, there is a related trophy here.
Scan surface in room.
Which surface?
Oh hey, there's the ventriloquist.
Isn't the warden too old for a puppet show?
Wait, that's Scar.
Yeah.
The Scarface and the Ventriloquist.
Gothen's Blackgate Penitentiary once had a gallows tree from which 313 criminals with death sentences were hanged.
The wood from the tree was widowed by an inmate into the puppet Scarface.
And that inmate was worth his height and was murdered by Arnold Wesker, a man who would soon fall under Scarface's influence.
While most believe that Scarface is simply a tool through which Wesker, as the criminal mastermind, the Ventriloquist, acts out a dark side to his personality.
Wesker himself believes that Scarface is possessed by the souls who died beneath the gallows tree and the puppet actually motivates him to commit the duo's many crimes.
I hear like Scarface is now like under like a woman is now the new Ventriloquist.
Because the original Ventriloquist fucking died.
So where is the secret?
You guys said there's a secret!
Where's the secret?
It's in the walls.
It's in the walls, Dokie!
It's in the walls!
That wall!
Thank you guys.
I really appreciate the guidance of the walls.
This wall?
I'm up against the wall.
Punch every wall.
Okay, now I actually don't know if I should...
I can't tell if you're fucking with me.
I cannot tell if you're fucking with me.
Left entrance.
Oh, secret has to use a gel.
A gel?
Okay, so...
But then I don't see it though.
Okay.
That wall.
If I keep... If I gel everything.
If I gel everything eventually.
Three gels.
There we go.
It was not that wall.
Right next... This one?
All will be gel.
Eventually... Oh, and the floor.
I guess.
And the floor.
Oh, three in the same place?
What?
Look up.
Why the fuck would I look up?
Okay.
It's technically the same place.
Wow!
I did it.
A floor... What is this?
What?
What's that?
Oh, is this Scarface?
Like...
Secret tunnel.
Look at the blueprint.
This one?
This blueprint?
Blueprint to a... Is this Arkham City?
Oh, is this like... Oh!
Oh, is this like a... Oh, zoom in?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Is this like a plan for...
Uh...
No?
Not letting me zoom.
This is a plan for the sequel, right?
Oh, that's cool.
It's like a sequel bait.
Well, I already know Arkham City was next.
Hahaha!
It just makes me think that... Because like back then, I feel like 10 years ago or 14 years ago, people don't really like...
Was it datamined stuff back then?
I mean, people did, I feel like.
I'm sure people did.
But like it wasn't as like intense as it was in the... as it is now, I feel like.
Wait, there must be like a cat and mouse here somewhere.
If it's like cat and mouse.
Yeah, it wasn't as common.
I feel like someone must have been like just fucking...
Just spraying every fucking wall.
That's pretty cool.
Alright, riddle me this.
Scan the display.
This one?
Which display?
Bathroom mirror, scan yourself.
There's a mirror?
There is no mirror here.
Yeah, I was gonna say it.
I feel like it has to be a display case.
Is that it?
Oh, there it is.
Catwoman.
An orphan who learned to survive on Gotham City streets.
Selina Kyle took to thievery to survive.
But determined to do it in style.
She learned martial arts and trained extensively to perfect her skills at cat burglary.
Her criminal activities are often tampered with by reluctant altruism.
Making her an inconstant...
Oh, he's like an anti-hero.
Is that the right word?
An inconstant villain and occasional hero.
She regularly eludes captured by the Dark Knight.
And maintains a complicated aversive relationship with Batman.
That frequently turns flirtatious and occasionally legitimately romantic.
Nice.
Oh, teeth!
That's right, Batman.
You got some.
Alright.
Does that save my game?
I think it does.
Alright!
We are gonna call it here, guys.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, I'm really tired.
I'm gonna call it here.
I had a long...
day.
Oh!
That was really fun, though!
That was really, really fun.
I've been enjoying Batman Arkham Asylum.
I'm so happy to actually be able to play this game now.
Because it's like, it's honestly been like a game I've been wanting to play for the longest time.
And...
It's honestly been...
It's been really fun.
I have to say.
It's actually been very, very fun so far.
And...
As someone that is like...
Really into like DC stuff.
It's like nice to...
And then like you guys too.
You guys like know everything I'm talking about.
It's just nice to like actually like talk about like the DC lore.
And like the DC comics and the DC shows and stuff like that.
Just talking about like superheroes and stuff.
So it's like nice to know you guys understand my references.
And even if you like didn't.
It's because you guys get to learn with me too.
But yeah.
Thank you everybody.
I noticed I wanted to do a super chat reading after this.
But I did read some super chats as we went along.
But I'm very, very tired right now.
So I'm going to call it here.
And rest up.
But thank you everybody.
I really enjoyed streaming today for you guys.
As always everyone.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up late for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
Helldivers 2 tomorrow.
And I hope that the servers won't be too bad tomorrow.
Guys.
Please.
I request you guys to not go.
To not play Helldivers 2.
So I can play on the server.
Guys.
I would like to be able to play Helldivers 2 tomorrow.
So please.
Let me have.
Let me get into the server.
No.
You have to.
Guys.
If you want to watch me play Helldivers 2.
You guys need to pause real quick.
And not play that day.
You can watch me play.
Live vicariously through me.
Anyway.
I'll see you guys later everybody.
Bye.